une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous aident à titre super content
avec mois d'août plantes
cette semaine le sans fil de présenter
encore une fois par terriens terriens
terriens terrain c'est un bureau de
comptables soit plus de 25 ans qui sont
ouverts
ils sont spécialisés dans les pme de 1 à
100 employés qui oeuvrent dans les
domaines d'avenir on parle
d'informatique on parle de jeux vidéo on
parle même d'une business de podcasts
comme la nôtre nous on a rencontré
therrien était rien pour discuter une
fiscalité puis nous ont vraiment aidés
ils ont aiguillé dans la bonne direction
ou est ce que nous on connaissait pas
grand chose dans tout sur puis ça nous a
vraiment aidés quand nous a éclairé
entre que puis ce qui ôte c'est qu'il ya
place d'avoir à place de certaines
grandes firmes qui ont plusieurs
plusieurs clients terrain terrain ils
sont vraiment il offre un service humain
un service individualisé à vos besoins
ce qui est super cool pis ils peuvent en
fait offrir un service clé en main ils
peuvent faire votre vos tenues de lire
vos états financiers les rapports
n'aient pas lui demander crédit d'impôt
tout seul tout dépend de vos besoins en
fait nous on établit avec eux sur nos
besoins qui vont prendre tout cela en
charge pour nous autres qui est super
cool
dirigez-vous vers therrien président ion
cpa points comme si vous avez envie
d'avoir recours à leurs services
et oubliez pas d'utiliser le code sans
filtre lorsque vous allez en fait
prendre votre première année avec eux
parce que ça va vous donner 50 % sur la
première année financière heures puis
vous allez pouvoir utiliser l'autre 50%
pour la mettre dans votre entreprise
donc therrien un trait d'union cpe point
com pour plus d'information là dessus
sinon y est sinon ça va dans leur si
étienne boulay un groupe pour être bien
honnête je connaissais pas tant je le
savais c'était qui mais on le bouquet
est un peu dernière minute puis est venu
ici ce matin puis ça a été un coup de
foudre
non mais je voudrais a critiqué qu'il
est ouvert à marcoule je pense qu'il ya
eu du fun aussi c'est ça de moi moi je
connais 0 football 0 point barre
ça que j'ai découvert cette semaine vers
le avec lui
c'était super intéressant super drôle
s'exprime super bien super gentil qu'on
a parlé de sa carrière de la nfl comment
ça fonctionne la cie efforts les parties
backstage qui se passe en dehors de
football
les restos à quinze mille pièces un
resto à quinze mille pièces qui est
aussi on a parlé des caisses qui fait
maintenant ses objectifs en a parlé un
petit peu de spray en mode de
développement personnel comment
atteindre ces objectifs
comment rester centré sur ses valeurs
dans cette business club titre super
belle rencontre pas beau pas de casse
encore une fois vraiment vraiment active
annonce en fait avant de vous laisser
sur le podcast d'un puits - on vient de
lancer le sans filtre vip voix qui est
un podcast ou est ce qui est
sensiblement fait la même chose que sur
le sans fil mais avec des gens de notre
entourage qu'on juge intéressant mais
qui sont moins connus du public
c'est disponible uniquement nos membres
petrone donc si vous voulez avoir accès
à ces podcasts là je vais mettre le lien
dans la décision du podcast cette
semaine on a reçu ma soeur marie lou
caron quentin on a parlé de deux
millions de trucs par rapport au
développement personnel
là c'est pas beau poker c'est vraiment
vraiment pas de dépression d'étudier la
médecine savourer la vie ou un petit
avis vraiment vraiment c'est le feu ne
s'est pas de casse le honnêtement si
vous aimez ce qu'on fait c'est vraiment
une des meilleures façons nous
encourager c'est de vous abonner à notre
pétrone puis en plus on a vu du contenu
exclusif comme celui là sinon une autre
façon nous encourager abonnez-vous à
notre chaîne commenté sous la vidéo sur
le podcast des commentaires sur balles à
dos apparemment que c'est vraiment bon
pour l'algorithme l'algorithme agi de
façon mystérieuse mais apparemment que
c'est bon les seniors waiting de cinq
étoiles parlez-en à vos amis d'alice et
surtout continuez à nous écouter
sextant plaisir de vous retrouver à
chaque semaine bon pas de casque bonne
écoute
[Musique]
ce n'est pas mes lecteurs sata disent
non mais c'est comme s'il savait film
sans écouteurs c'est comme si le sérieux
du projet faisait on disait juste 25 ans
vous êtes crossfit en fait j'en ai fait
pas après la carrière j'ai beaucoup
aussi de me chercher moi de prendre
l'énergie comme l'analyse de ceux d'un
côté bon pour comme on peut recommencer
au bas de l'échelle dans à tout faire de
l'argent je vois cela dit j'ai en ai
fait pas mal puis j'ai beaucoup aimé ça
mais mon corps il est quand même à
gagner le droit des années de foi doit
on avait à konya toujours fait que
j'aime encore beaucoup sur mais je sais
que faut que je dose parce que sinon je
devine j'ai mal partout puis j'oubliais
et moi on sait que l'on peut tout me tim
howard un gars qui fait les trucs de
façon tempère je vois les jeunes et que
je me sens prêt nez avec un gars qui
s'appelle alba dominique laroche qui
avait fait les games ce sont les espèces
de compétition puis chaque fois que je
m'entraînais avec lui une machine puis
j'essaie de le suivre
dites-le mettons une journée j'étais
capable de le suivre de binbin fia qui
est là mais moi je te donne ça marche
est plus que capable de continuer à
pousser avec g aucune capacité à me dire
comme elle le vaut une relaxe
aujourd'hui je me suis je rendais maison
un après-midi pige parvient jamais à
blanc là j'ai squatté qu'athlète
mais comme dans l'temps fait que la
mesure clé mais sa réponse que mai mais
que ça fait mais ces silos michael bay
ben ouais mais y'a de quoi dans certains
objectifs
mais il y aussi un voile a été déjà
lancé monique moi oui et acquiert je
travaille un peu plus qu'un casse j'ai
fini de ma carrière d'un joueur ce que
j'ai mangé pendant à peu près 20 ans
avec le rouge et or puis quand j'ai fini
ma carrière d'un joueur
j'allais au jam que le jeu bencher je me
disais pourquoi qu'est ce que j'étais en
train d'essayer de faire je vous donnais
plus fort good good good mais qu'à ça va
m'arriver d'avoir besoin cette force là
dans une envie de tous les jours c'est
quoi c'est le double au travail est
d'accord on a une peau d'un combo manuel
pour deux raisons mais amman et c'est
qu'on essaie de conserver nos bonnes
habitudes comme si le temps de rien
n'est aussi c'est bon pour ta j'ai
commencé à courir si je trouvais que
c'était mieux pour ma santé que d'aller
au jim celle de jack white cube cousin
c'est super simple oui mais moi j'ai
aucune motivation les faux j'essaie
jogging mais mes genoux enfin non c'est
un monde au bord j'étais juge comme je
peux juste corée sur le gazon - pour pas
avoir mal ne pas ménager beaucoup
beaucoup de difficultés puis je sais que
j'ai la rage et puis je fais comme un
jeu honnêtement je dois m'entraîner
peut-être deux trois fois par mois il
s'est assis le tueur j'essaie que je
m'étais fixé comme objectif de
recommencer le depuis quelque temps je
fais bien attention à mon alimentation
parce que tu peux pas t'entraîner mais
tu peux pourtant très mal est fait
j'espère qu'un commencé tranquillement
je veux reprendre une certaine
motivation mais tu es allé au jim jeu
mais quand le pana bhutta j'avais essayé
avec une coupe de bosses de jouer au
basket dans un élevage pour un peu de
rock effectivement le dégage de là
qu'ils ont tant de moyens je suis pas
bon je souffre et est un fabricant dans
lequel des pubs ont fait que je navigue
encore dans l'espèce d'après kayak mais
cherche beaucoup sur la chaîne que
j'avais travaillé avec eux je mets des
chalets plus l'os
je pense mais je passais pas sinon tu te
retrouves et le sport où l'activité qui
quitte le mais j'aurais le goût de jouer
au tennis on attend mais moi je suis
creux en montérégie qui tous mes voisins
ont des jobs en guillemets normale au
tilt du lundi au vendredi aux autres
d'une façon moi d'aller jouer au tennis
c'est un mardi à 10 heures ça me
tenterait j'ai comme pas de porte ne
fait que le chp assez intenses et
sérieux lada pour joindre une ligue avec
des espèces de tournois de tennis
pourrait à moins que ça prend vraiment
un bon niveau pour être capable de faire
du cardio la balle sinon rien qui se
passe je n'ai pas des changes il faut
que tu es un bon niveau pour être comme
la natation en mettant la natation
c'était pas que c'est au point une
technique correcte tu peux pas un fils
est longue
tu peux pas capable mais ce qui était
d'arrêter faire un sport où c'est toute
son horreur et organisé autour de tous
tes entraînements il quelqu'un qui fait
on aura pour toi te jure s'être
présentés tous pour votre question c'est
au delà de l'entraînement c'est ce qui
est plutôt fier que moi tu es pris en
charge
exactement dès les premières années au
dessus au dessus est ce que les
premières années du commerce à
t'entraîner d'un coach qui te dis quoi
vraiment un coach qui jette on arrête
l'école qui qui allie de cette étude
était guettée pratiques passées de ceux
chez les pros ça m'a fait montre à sion
carrière c'est notre truc que j'ai
trouvé difficile c'est que pour la
première fois faut que je gère mes
propres journée avec le travail c'est ce
que j'ai pas été capable en fait ces
deux jets de lave on dirait que j'ai
grandi dans un point où je veux
continuer à améliorer mes faiblesses
mais mandat c'est comme j'ai 36 ans je
sait dans quoi je suis bon et moins bon
alors que tout le monde est toujours en
train de dire améliorer d'un côté bâbord
oui pendant votre femme anne et réaliste
c'est comme moi ce que j'aime ici c'est
ce qu'on est bons exactement finale
je veux avoir une compréhension générale
de la structure de comminges plus elle
mais gérer ça au détour des jeux les
poches je suis je déprime frustré fait
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui m'a il faut y
mettre le double d'efforts pour
apprendre à faire la chose qui était pas
bon c'est plutôt que tout s'est enchaîné
je pense mettre quelque part dans lequel
je suis bon mais si si mais d'avancer
c'est juste deux exemples mettre les
bons les bonnes personnes aux bonnes
places
l'équipe et puis comme ça je pensais que
sur l'autre fois qu'un cas qui étaient
ici sur le podcast puis c'était un nom
de teintes finir dans une journée les
deux points fini de tourner à la fin
comme un nombre limité de temps puis
amman et si tu en penses à faire du
ménage organisa journée voilé lunch
massif à ce qu'est ce qui te reste c'est
parce qu'on veut tout plus mais c'est
parce qu'à man il faut qu'ils regardent
aussi qu'est ce que tu fais avec ton
arts afac toute l'espèce de grévy j'ai
le luxe où je suis rendue maintenant de
pouvoir engager du monde ou si on veut
dispatcher déléguer certaines afap puis
ça je trouve que c'est un whist une
dépense mais en même temps ça va me
permettre de whisky de brainstorm et
puis d'avancer ces affaires qui me
tombent exactement c'est chez nous avec
ma blonde comme les ménages devenir une
source de conflit déjà si vous êtes le
seul couple si c'est toute cette
histoire qui est moindre amorce même
mois ses carnets saisis passer
l'aspirateur ça me fait chier cette
année que moi mais ton monte rigueur
était plus bas que le sien
oui c'était moi qui le faisait de ce
système qui prenaient l'initiative de
passer l'aspirateur parce que l'exposé
la frustration des coupes si fragile
fait que je suis folle date on veut mais
l'auto dessus de problème
c'est une fois que d'engager une femme
de ménage d'automne ce problème c'est
qu'il faut ranger la femme de ménage a
fait que tu as comme la veille que la
femme de ménage l'arrêt devant
excuse moi je trouve ça déménage on dit
que cantona dise quand on part pour un
quatre et demi de son insu si je joue
comme ça leur tente comme une coupe de
semaine puis ça m'a un peu déprimé à 37
[Rires]
ans mais j'ai prêté mon café le matin
devant la porte patio puis j'ai passé un
bon cinq minutes a admis rimer et c'est
juste la bonne hauteur ça coupe les
voisins mais le soleil ne mérite
vraiment pas fait quand j'ai quand même
pris un coup de vieux
j'ai vraiment des banners que justement
ados ou jeunes adultes déjà je serai
jamais cette personne la vie avec mes
parents mes temps qui passe est
tellement gérer la piscine d'agir au
plus vite à montréal puis il fait fort
king show puis je me dis que j'aimerais
c'est jusqu'à tôt rien à faire là
dimanche après le dit sors tu vas mettre
les produits dedans tu fais le bakoye
c'est moi c'est moi d en face b un
sentiment d'accomplissement
c'est mon pagne médecin genre ils sont
des vies mais genre la piscine c'est ce
qu'ils aiment fiable
j'ai essayé c'est quoi apprécions
carrière encore une fois beaucoup remis
en question
j'avais plein d'amis dans mon entourage
qui sont super manuel qui sont capables
de faire des gosses de la maison qui me
dit souvent soit bien fait que je parte
ici comme sur une balle au chalet gens
au rhône
j'ai acheté pour
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent doughty
beaucoup beaucoup
encore une fois aucun équilibre excessif
aux beaufs et que j'achète plein
d'outils une table à six a dit je suis
fier de poser leurs mois dans le garage
mais pas d'armor une étagère ce qu'ils
accordent encore pdm chambre à l'acte
je n'ai ressenti aucune valorisation
souhaitant je voyage est quelqu'un qu'on
fasse sur son bon là dedans le c'était
impressionnant
si le fait de mal à faire de nous mêmes
et juste mettons faire le trou pour le
tuyau de l'évier dans le bruxelles au
nom même télé c'est comment qu'on va
faire ce qu'ils savent être crochet sur
le monsieur de l'immeuble eeci viennent
si on demandait comment confessions et
roux compris le prince william vois je
suis multi claque deux minutes catherine
kapsiki l'aménagement studio on a la
chance c'était à coup de trois quatre
fois par jour afin qu'on a besoin d'eux
s'est aussi retourné genre la team had a
marqué ça nous voyait 4 nages on est
allé chercher dit et je vous reconnais
les gueuses sont allés au bénin à côté
vous pouvez prendre un panier et on peut
ramener le panier voilà ça a quand même
un atout extraordinaire
j'te peu un vieux déjà qu'ils sont
capables sur manucure débrouille éthique
comme quelqu'un capable la limite de se
bâtir une maison
moi je me dis toujours il ya une vraie
apocalypse de scie où il ya quelque
chose qui se parlent touche dans ma
werss que je pourrais pas déléguer parce
que tout le monde vont se sauver à
poggio et s6 avait comme une attaque de
zombies de survie des légendes qui
des premières parties est-ce que je
convie de métier mais watch je te ferai
pas la renta j'ai l'impression que c'est
le cas de beaucoup d'athlètes
d'excellence qui ont passé toute leur
vie à pocus et sur ce qu'il a tellement
précisément que je dois tu es capable il
patine superbe voix la gauche mais on a
pratiqué un autre kraft foods de façon
spécifique
charles bezanger tous déjà mauges
arrêter ce pas longtemps à laval aussi
way sidro cela va justement parce que
mettons 4/10 aux archives genre dans le
rouge et or le monde font genre football
puis le nom natation puis alors que les
autres parce que je crois pas que la
vache à lait soutenir sa fille n'en sort
carrément c'est beaucoup comme ça aux
etats-unis aussi enfin si glen
constantin le coche au coach et à
houston en début de carrière donc toutes
les formes à l'université américaine je
pense qu'il le laisse un peu ce qui a
transposé à la battait avec les espèces
de les anciens qui booste le club aussi
plus ni le tiède à faire rejaillir toute
l'université au complet fait que c'est
quelque chose de beau
l'autre jour j'ai appris
moi j'étais sûr que tu as fait ton
parcours universitaire au québec
ouais j'étais sûr et certain mais non tu
es tu allé aux études ouais je voulais
percer aux states et parce que d'alter
g36 l'université laval
le programme a commencé je me suis pitre
aucun mais c'était n'étaient pas encore
connus les carabins avaient pas d équipe
ne l'a guère dynamisé you commencé plus
tôt ou plus tard avec moi l'avenue la
plus je trouvais solide pour me faire
recruter ou dans la nfl ou dans les cff
étaient passés par les universités
américaines là encore même exactitude
épinière c'est comme le rock you québec
ceux des pillards de foot la botte le
maire coaching de mériter notre équipe
après mon secondaire j'ai tout de suite
allé aux états unis j'ai une bourse pour
aller faire l'équivalent du cégep plus
de deux ans dans un prep school
américain au connecticut à produire sur
une autre bourse pour aller à
l'université
une version et monsieur l'université de
nîmes sur ses divisions saison 1-2 fait
un saut et en battant lé michigan
les grenats le kit puis 1 2 c en dessous
mais on joue en contre l'hôte à quelques
reprises dans la saison qui se soucie
c'est une expérience moi je me rappelle
j'avais eu des offres dans deux
universités pour un score à deux
chiffres aux états unis mais sa division
deux petits gars de natation était mieux
ou est ce que je t'ai world mais ça ça
reste une expérience complètement débile
mais c'est 2 1
l'adaptation dans un autre pays team g
j'avais 16 ans et taquin quand j'ai
déménagé celle effectuée à sa résidence
au début l'anglais est une langue
seconde pour moi je connaissais ses
focales apparaître les cours d'anglais
qu'on a eue au secondaire ou du
porte-monnaie ça m'a tout attention non
au oui
peu importe les cours d'anglais c'est
l'immersion exact
au début tu rêves en espèces de francs
ouais parler au petit fils effectuent
beaucoup à l'apprentissage mais tu
qatari votées depuis ton nom c'est
etienne ouais déjà là comme tu peux pas
comme le tout à fait moi le truc
nicole mais non je sais comme étienne
machine mais après le vote
jouffre est alloué
[Rires]
je les ai déjà fait de montrer tonton
tellement gêné plat qui était tellement
belle pis je vous explique un peu
comment je me sentais la baule et
première année d'une école de riches
mais ultra riches et mon père blanc
portait un espèce de toyota est qu on
n'avait pas beaucoup de sous en grande
s'appuie à côté c'était les batteries
les oiseaux avec toutes les filles c'est
s'intéressait à moi parce que j'étais en
échec parce que j'étais gentil 6e mais
jamais rien de sérieux
c'était quoi sont en cause qui voulait
ce match et avait un petit ami chez vous
le connaissez quand blake et des ja une
fille qui m'a tiré son nom s'était
adjoint et une magnifique brunette jeu
qui a peut-être subi première année ça
veut rien savoir mais ça vaut deuxième
année on commence à jaser un petit peu
pigeons dans ma résidence puis jeu
tellement j'ai aimé
on n'a aucune espèce gaza passe pour le
court et je les invite à s'asseoir se
dit va pas regarder - l'équipe de foot
je sais que ça se passait comme partager
ce qui est bon de gaza tv puis mais
c'est pas qu'elle aime ça comme so foot
je fasse d'autre chose puis damages
l'échappée royale et sa femme alors
ouais ouais c'était bon mais là c'est
bon l'une des affaires qui empêche les
gens d'aller d'aller aux états unis
moche et mathieu bête qui graffite et
paraissent cassés fait signer à genlis
je pense à chicago puis l'une des
affaires qui parce qu'il y aurait pu
aller aux states une affaire qui retient
ces gens là c'est de se dire je pourrais
être le numéro 1 dans un programme comme
le rouge et or et ben je veux prendre ma
chance dans un bassin où est ce que je
suis doit être le numéro 30 mois ces
caisses qui sait quand arrive le ska un
bang un bon si c'est quoi le pourcentage
de personnes qui sont drafté mettons en
effet dans d'envié je connais pas le
chiffre exact est exempt de 2 3% exact
ça doit être trop minime j'avais en tête
justement 3% ti je pense qu'à partir du
reich court j'avais déjà une star c'est
0,01 pour cent de toutes les joueurs de
foot qui joue au secondaire aux états
unis qui m'ont réservé de 0,6 avec jamie
bell qui vont avoir raison tout être
joué sur l'équipe b jardin et de
pratiques de l'importance d'allier le
foot aux études oui tpiy achetant il y
en a pas de bonne ou de mauvaise réponse
parce que le niveau
le calibre au canada a tellement été
élevé entre autres grâce aux apports du
rouge et or
puis je dois dire aussi d'un gars qui
s'appelle laurent dubernais tardif et
exane est qu'il ya encore plus paris la
voiture j'ai eu un tour ailleurs dans
les fêtes j'ai passé neuf mois la boîte
les jets de new york après moyens et
samuel giguère qui a fait 4 à la bo
particulièrement
principalement sur l'équipe de pratique
en fait je trouve qu'on a été peut-être
on a ouvert la voie un peu puis laurent
est arrivé avec son talent avec son
charisme avec avec toutes les attitudes
qui au pire comme déversés à la porte
puis la voie est ouverte si fécond être
conscient aussi qu'on a du talent québec
quand j'ai commencé à jouer au foot mais
comme j'avais pas jouer au foot fait que
c'était des passionnés des pédagogues
d'ego qui voyait qu'il y avait quelque
chose d'intéressant dans ce sport
olympique qui sont impliqués c'est
génial mais la star de des anciens comme
moi comme d'autres qui vont graduée qui
vont jouer pro qui vont jouer au haut
niveau il après ceux qui m'ont emmené
recrute chez les jeunes fait que si tout
se fait en sorte que ça augmente le
niveau métier toujours peu importe que
tu te fasses recruté par le cégep c'est
en avant vers impériale sous une équipe
b mais toujours une que sa position de
beaulieu est-ce que choisi d'attendre
puis de moins jouer mais peut-être me
faire former de malfaçons ou est ce que
j'y vais avec le temps de glace le temps
de jeu puis là je vois à prendre avec
l'expérience qu'il est les deux sondes
est battable n'y a pas de bonne ou
mauvaise réponse visiblement ça a
fonctionné pour mathieu baisse parce
qu'il rend du lot bordent la frontière
pour donald usa allaient bien s'y met
mais oui ça se vaut souvent surtout dans
les incidents les gros programme attend
ici d'un qbe que pas joué pendant trois
ans sa dernière saison il ya en barque
et joue quatre sanguins et le paf et
sucre repêché dans parce que c'est une
machine qui y ont appris pendant
longtemps derrière les pros trigano tom
brady quand même passé quelques années
sur le banc derrière un dénommé double
dessous de ces faits s'il y avait eu
peut-être la grosse tête mais moi
j'avais une équipe qui joue et de suite
peut-être moules à la carrera cup
il s'est fait de l'acheter loin en plus
le jeu ma 198 c'est fou la potasse et
j'ai su quelque chose qui est fait je
pensais à ce que moi je pense qu'avec 12
quart-arrière mans lui qui ont pas ce
genre d'autres polyrey du michigan
défaut ça ça vient prouver que comme
c'est beau à voir des stats
tu as beau avoir les chiffres y avoir
scoré aux tests physiques de la nfl
entre autres il ya comme un un game
facteurs qui comme pau évaluables avec
des tests c'est du gameplay assez
d'expérience visé aussi c'est quoi et
comme dans tout les métiers dans le
vôtre aussi pierre natation au sommet
mais quand
la pression est à son pic comment est ce
que quelqu'un réagisse
il y en a qui s'écroule puis c'est pas
ce pas de leur faute c'est juste cette
façon le piano c'est presque normal
parce que c'est tellement apprécié ce
que c'est ce qui est normal de
tranquille sans papiers gras c'est
justement ces deux contrats qui sont ces
allégations et encore plus plus
visiblement le mais j'avais entendu ce
que je le dis le jour où il a été drafté
par les passes captées du raft et les
trams de même ces mots garantie que tu
fasses le club lions de données d'achat
ce qui est allé voir robert kraft
la première journée là bas qui est
propriétaire de l'équipe j'ai serré la
main pied dit je suis la meilleure
décision que toro jamais pris ta vie y
est on pouvait dire c'est quand même
c'est un peu kaki mais quand les
livraisons c'est mayotte est le facteur
les autres focus quand quelle la
pression mais il ya aussi le facteur
coquine s ouais c'est tu peux pas percé
dans quelque chose d'aussi compétitif si
ce n'est pas 100% confiance en ce que tu
peux faire pour ceux qui vivent les
athlète d'handisport comme seuil c'est
qu'ils sont en conférence de presse puis
c'est comme si moi de shit le dit mais
je comprends parce que c'est ça brasse
je pense que le l'extrême de ce côté
coquilles
ça va être les boxeurs 28e des joueurs
de photos des joueurs de basket à 6 mais
les boxers et on va avoir une équipe
qu'il est mon il ya embarque tout seul
son dans le ring puis joue pas à la boxe
visiblement on le voit avec la situation
des données stevenson paix avec d'autres
des huit omd comme si cette élection qui
ont eu des parcours malheureuse que les
conséquences peuvent être vraiment
vraiment dramatique c'est fait je la
comprends cette espèce d'exubérance
l'appui le cas qui n'est ce qui est des
barres d'appui qui vaut des fois bien
trop loin
ce qui vaut au niveau perso mais comme
top pas chouette mais dans cette espèce
d'état d'esprit là parce que sinon c'est
une fraction de seconde qui peut
vraiment
beatty un côté théâtral aussi là dedans
gemma bombarde pour ça c est que tu
regardes les cartes de boxe samedi ou
même le wef si tu le sais qu'un tel ce
beau contingent un bon pique à aucune
chance mais tu regardes le build up tu
fais comme sept secondes plus tard
c'était passé avec 15 mai google était
ali et boksic alfred mongy croyait floyd
mayweather c'est juste un argument ta
ble ment le meilleur boxeur de tous
l'état et jamais perdu une fiche de
comme 60,02 jamais perdu je pense que
c'est une réaction épaules devant sa
défense il cycle et si jamais fait qu'un
film est il juste un bonheur rare qui le
reconnaît mais gaullien combattants du
ufc qui décide d'aller se battre
concluant boxty puis le à cause du build
up tout le monde a faim c'est comme en
ont connu a vraiment une chance car être
mangé oui j'ai fait un énorme pas ta
maison poursuit c'était comme une excuse
mais mais oui de la build up est extradé
mais c'est aussi ça laisse présager
comme la suite du monde de
l'entertainment qui commence à voir des
coureurs sur vu dans pleinement
puis juste dans le but et ça c'est le
côté business
ils y ont accepté de faire ce combo
l'eau je me suis le wef six bogeys
pendant bhutta parce que le yuv s'ils
voulaient une partie de la tarte de des
revenus que ça allait ça allait générer
et vous voyez un effectif à l'équipe qui
donne un petit pourcentage audio ici
pour me permettre à mais google allait
se battre en boxe mais ça revient de
plus en plus axé vers le business
cela peut générer comme spectacle 350
millions faite pour ce combo l'a350
c'est fou les formations
au total a fait une coupe mais
contiendraient des pommades plus mal en
point
j'ai quand même des limitations non
voilà l'art on oublie ses deux chiens
pour faire de moi je fais que mal de
coeur instantané je me sens comme dans
un vrai geek comme si j'étais ben ouais
ouais ouais je te l'avais dit que la
famille avec un ami qui lui aussi a une
commotion pas maintenant le fait comme
nous et qu'on fait pour ma naïveté on le
fait à deux celui de super space
mountain genre s il fait noir puis ouais
c'est ça des étoiles total buts dans ces
écarts à la sortie de lost et gris je
suis le plus bas a tout fait que
trampoline de 10 à faire de même indiqué
quand ça brasse le on voit ce qu'il faut
que je fasse attention fait que
l'enfoncer que j'étais un peu plus
calmes et mm
je vois ça va loin le géant en un tapis
roulant nouveau dans notre djemaa maison
puis ça me choque aussi c'est quand le
courir fait être en mouvement mais voir
que ribes aujourd'hui cette chute est
une des les arguments de dire qu'il faut
que j'arrête là que huawei absolument
absolue 2012 après avoir gagné la coupe
je revenais à montréal j'ai vu aussi
commencé à faire le pas été pas mal
l'effectif alors qu'un athlète vieilli
il faut passer encore plus de temps
la page suivante puis j'avais pu cette
espèce d'énergie et j'avais vraiment
comme une envie de décrocher pour la
pente et puis je le voyais bien que
j'étais plus je te plus le même
j'étais plus que 22 km je me suis comme
identifier mon branding stade est un
petit qu'un peu le syndrome de paul et à
partir du moment où tu es peut être
soudain ouais ben c'est sûr ça change la
game que j'avais pu les j'avais plus
envie de faire les efforts en commun
avec ça comme tout ça contribue ps
casque et après si tu t'es je pense
c'est informer le plus le pour
comprendre le phénomène des commotions
comment ça c'est que les symptômes de
type 1 pis on en est ou parce que je
pense qu'on est encore méconnu quand
même c'est quoi exactement les symptômes
qui commence et celui longtemps parce
que des fois ça faisait neuf qui
achetaient donc comme un s'instaurer un
protocole de retour au jeu avant quand
on joue au foot démérité se tait
combien de doigts trop parfait et quand
même chez les projets un cockpit ce qui
est interdit aux bains et dit au médecin
j'ai mal aux yeux
j'ai mal aux yeux de la lumière mérillon
mine mais c'est là donc on connaissait
pas mieux tu y fais quoi maintenant on
est vraiment sensibiliser à ce c'est une
commotion en fait quand j'ai lu la
définition c'est qu'à chaque fois que tu
cognes ou que tu tombes au touquet
oye-plage peu importe le contact ni que
tout comme une perte de vision est
embrouillée août ml quelques secondes
mais moi j'ai calculé pas comme des
commotions dans le temps parce qu'après
3 4 secondes c'est revenait je me fonde
mal de tête je me disais l'autre des
cidres et et des petites formations à
chaque fois
en fait ça a été exponentielle c'est le
début de ma carrière pro jamais un lama
niveau c'est bien mais la présence à ces
enveloppes la passe et ça arrive plus
ouvert plus qu'en fait elle est plus
qu'essentiel exacte à partir de marotte
était quelque peu de cas c'est un bon
groupe c'est que quelqu'un va revenir à
100% dans quelques mois à partir du
moment où tu es une commotion cérébrale
tu es toujours un peu fragilisé beats
agréable d'en virer tout en avait une
grosse en 2011 2011 24 juillet 2011
puis j'ai eu bien fait c'est que quitte
à douvres et dans le fond
on jouait contre saskatchewan d'un de
mettre leur carrière
un gros bonhomme présent à 230 et 235
livres conserve le ballon se faufile
puis un cubi qui conserve le ballon foot
devient une cible
comme je dis souvent mon objectif c'est
pas mal mais poster exact fictif de la
ligne puis moi j'ai toujours appris à
cogner avec ma tête parce que c'est la
partie la plus dure de ton corps perdu
un peu importe mais ce besoin d'un
simple ce fait que les aligner on a fait
la casse a cassé avec une image de linge
avec un agenda mais en plus il s'est
fait plaquer par en arrière par john
bowman meco qui piquent pas 278 ma nuque
dumas ma tête comme attraper toutes ces
chocs le fait qu en me relevant je te
tue c'est même pas le contact le plus
sévère au monde si je regarde des vidéos
sa fesse ne t'attends pas les casques
claqué comme ça dit que met pas la
pression je t'ai tout mais les vis et je
suis jamais revenu ça a pris je disais
je vois rester sur terre et rester sept
terrains pendant quatre cinq minutes
d'antenne à prendre ce constat vaut
partir et puis ça c'est parti pour
pendant combien de temps je te dis j'ai
été une couple de semaines j'ai vraiment
accroché leur ajouter à ce cas plus que
je suis fils est pas bien j'ai commencé
à moto médicamenté petit qu'un peu
j'avais déjà la fib excessive
j'avais des jeux cgt il passerait au
foot depuis jeudi par intense quand je
faisais le pas été si je l'avais déjà
c'est comme si la commotion amplifiées
tout ce fric
moi j'avais accès si on souffre on ce
contrepoids de matri le sport
professionnel on va prendre des
antidouleurs défaut petit médecins
veulent prendre pour finir la gamescom
est administré par l'équipe six mois
j'ai commencé à apprendre par moi même
j'avais une façon d'en obtenir puis le
sait pas dire non si c'était des perco
sceptre et des oxydes et rue comme ceux
des ménages mais le truc qui quittent
créé des barbades exact qu'à partir du
moment où temps après a pas pour finir
une game est temps après pour feeling
normal mardi après midi
il ya un problème sauf que la drogue
fait ce que ça fait de mieux c'est que
ça tu accroches moi j cette histoire
leur a été réécrite des centaines de
milliers de fois des millions de fois
man et la dose que tu prends fait plus
effet fekter prend d'autres venus du
mérite beaujoire autre chose tu fais que
moi c'est un peu comme ce que c'est la
commande
descente aux enfers ce team et on casse
un bras comme tu dis ça va revenir
mais le cerveau même temps un justin le
jeu sort puis il est tellement complexe
que je souhaite leur jeu mais c'est ça
qu'il m'a eu des commotions je les sers
et haute en ajustant un pays voisin
je voudrais sur le coup tu que tu senti
mes tantes avait eu la conscience parce
qu'eux mêmes systèmes on n'en parlait
pas autant vis ta vie tu la conscience
de dire mettons l'oeil le ya quelque
chose qui vient de se passer que qui est
problématique
ou bien c'était comme un style le
souhait de geler ses fonctions ça va
finir le jeu je savais que c'était pas
normal puis c'était pire que d'habitude
mais en même temps tu es dans le feu de
l'action fait tu dis regarde dans
quelques secondes ça va se tasser en
même temps garde pas prêt il faut que je
voulais c'est comme si on réalise pas
vraiment conséquences au delà de tout la
vérité c'est que ce que je vous ai aussi
un effet si dans sport professionnel
très inquiet dans le real qui veut ta
place - c'est parti de la gamme de la
compétition on parle souvent de
compétition contre les autres équipes de
la compétition alain terne
il y en a marre je préfère parler entre
mois puis matthieu proulx qui jouait le
même chose que moi qui était un ami
c'était gérer sainement entre nous deux
et puis avec les coaches mais des fois
la compétition devient malsaine au sein
d'une même équipe absolument absolument
tout dépend de la gestion de la maturité
des joueurs puis de la gestion de
l'entraîneur mais mon point c'est que le
quai d'honneur de moins accès direct je
me trompe l'oeil il était dans l'est une
belle carrière coûtait pas cher plus
jeunes avec un potentiel extraordinaire
je sais très bien comment ça fonctionne
c'est un vétéran qui se blesse une
opportunité pour un jeune de france
épreuve d'acquérir l'expérience au
football les contrôles peuvent être
qu'en cellule aller contre istres
organiser les contres sont pas cassés
cordelette mahfoud et panama
2 de v terrain donc ça commence son
année recrue je donne des chiffres au
hasard parce que je peux expliquer que
la convention collective de
l'association des joueurs j'ai été
condamné mais de 18 game de saison
régulière son année recrue à tout moment
tu peux te faire couper puis doivent pas
leur reste de ton salaire
après deux ans et la deuxième année
c'est après quinze mêmes sources après
10 km et précieux après 5 des effectifs
quand est un vétéran du groupe d'année
c'est exactement c'est quand la game
après laquelle tu est garantie si le
reste de ton salaire jusqu'à ce le fait
que en fait on est de la seule ligue pas
la seule règle en effet c'est la même
chose aussi on est le seul spa houle
avantages contractuels à ce niveau là
est vraiment aux équipes ça a du bon et
du moins bon évidemment le bon la dass
et gm et tassements sûreté le rythme
mais rien de garanti fait que des
avantages
il ya beaucoup de sécurité puis à
beaucoup de roulement entre les joies en
fait c'est ton point c'est vrai tu me
laisses les paramètres radio dans saison
c 17 qui me coupe et doivent plus rien
mais par contre été blessée mais est ce
que ça fonctionne comme sur la sauce par
la cause que plus de blessures que
n'endosse pas peut-être parce
qu'historiquement ça a été comme ceux
aussi depuis longtemps mais disent tu
regarde le portrait business marre du
foot comparativement aux autres partis
si c'est un modèle dont beaucoup
beaucoup de joueurs à payer
pitau peu de game c'est parce que tu
peux jouer un match par semaine fait
c'est s'y est fait de 18 matchs donc
comme l'apport en doutant 9 à domicile
fecteau 9 games pour faire de l'argent
mais tu as 46 go à payer plus les gosses
sur l'équipe de pratique plus légaux
blessés plus tôt ou tard plus
l'administration parce que j'ai fait ça
fait beaucoup non alors que si on
compare par exemple l'autre extrême
baseball majeur de 160 ging fecteau 80
games pour faire de l'argent
ces petites cartes c'est dix fois plus
vite je sais pas combien de buts jamais
joué au baseball mais je passe tout
comme 15 gros problèmes à max dans une
équipe
être 20 sites des espèces de google qui
font appel d'arn avec les ligues
mineures mais des passes - peu plus de
revenus faict ces niveaux le jeu passer
pour ce que star organisé comme ça avec
pour donner l'avantagé aux organisations
je comprends le break en france parce
que c'est u2 compte depuis toujours
toutes les wii est un jeu c'est un peu
ça s'est passé à magny les hameaux
quand une équipe de football écoute
toutes les guerres quand une équipe je
me retrouve un temps que la rock et puis
le basket c'est 80 de game je trouve que
c'est beaucoup
ouais donc sept jours de suite 82 game
le basket c'est cool écouter le dernier
quart c'est exact les clients sont
erratiques game au complet de saison
régulière les trois premiers corps mais
métier je trouve que le football mais je
m'y intéresse de plus en plus au cours
des dernières années puis je trouve ça
vraiment le fun comme comme c'est un
genre de 15 semaines moi ce que tu te
lèves le matin bleu de côté expliqué sur
un blog officiel aussi exact et lyon la
nfl entre autres fait un travail
extraordinaire au niveau de la cie du
thé de leur match le dimanche c'est
football le web et on fait un happening
le monday night football
et puis là où ils ont ils iront en
italie depuis quelques années le net
avec le portrait football disons qu'on
se transpose en amérique les vendredis
soirs ça va souvent durs s coup s coulé
samedi encore le dimanche un effet petit
point en ordre de croissance ou si tu es
plus petits niveaux niveaux presque pro
les profits faits que dans le fond de ta
fin de semaine et comme tout s'était
déroulé l'accident
c'est le démantèlement a fait une job
aussi de d'accrocher oui les fans de
foot
d'accrocher les néophytes aussi le
système penning familiale comment
intéresser les enfants comment
intéresser les ventes y regarde le super
bowl y en a pour tous les goûts les peu
le show de la mi temps personne
tellement le monde qui goutte de trop
nasheed
que quand tu as été que les gestes
dessus du tout tu jouais dans un verre
d'eau peut jouer j'ai fait les pratiques
j'ai fait les mini camps j'ai fait un
beau disque à l'entraînement j'étais
coupé avant avant le premier match
présaison en fait ça coïncide le jour
j'étais coupé ces deux jours ils y ont
amené brett favre
on sortait de sa retraite gmac est temps
que je me suis dit à la blague que les
lacets de la place de cap salarial parce
qu'on avait salaces et là je m'en allais
ça ressemble à quoi
un salaire pour ce poste lui qui est si
ça dérange pas du tout pas du tout pu me
semblait apprécier la pression pour le
comparer que la cfl bon alors comment
c'est quoi ça ressemble moi j'ai signé
au salaire minimum parce que j'arrivais
avec aucun fait je l'égérie je pense
l'avoir mal gérée mais je le regrette
pas dans le sens où j'avais une
opportunité j'ai sauté à pieds joints
dedans après ma deuxième saison aux
alouettes je savais que j'allais avoir
des des essais les redskins de
washington me courait après depuis mon
année recrue mais il ya eu un changement
de coach au niveau de l'organisation à
préfecture à washington des fêtes mois
de janvier fin saison 2007 début 2008
mon agent avec qui je parlais tout le
temps me dis ok premier ou un premier
aux cartes vont avoir à peu près 11.42
selon mes calculs il parle à toutes les
équipes no 11 qui vont donner c'est le
premier cd est des billes de bois flou
fait pas et me fait pas beau flou
jeffrey howard carter n'a pas pris à 10
voix mais on ça veut dire que tu vaux
voler en place pour pratiquer l'exacte a
fait même pas pratiqué que l'équipe
ils vont évaluer dans leurs locaux leur
installation de musique de l'exacte fake
j'arrive à bouafles au vieux 5/10 line
qui sont évalués puis à 5,2 me défensif
de gama pouce au rectorat parmi 10
jusqu'à revient mais
à pilonner temps pour parler après y'a
rien pour rien qui aboutit deux jours
plus tard justin aux jets à new york
c'est aux jets à new york j'arrive le
sait vraiment honnêtement j'ai rarement
été aussi nerveux la veille tu es tout
seul à l'hôtel c'est la faulx king nf1
culmine c'est ce que tu rêve depuis tout
petit puis non seulement c'est ce que tu
rêves j'ai pas eu aucun contact avec la
nfl fait met en doute tic des fautes on
regarde les athlètes le monde pense
qu'on est super confiant mais je me
remets en question continue d'empiler
j'ai la chienne je veux pas échoué
estime que ce faisant aucun contact
n'est pas dans le sens où j'ai grandi au
canada ou en qu'éclate voilà en effet 3
quel point c'est grandiose
shaw est injuste pour les l'opening de
télé de la game
petit fait commerce est plus grand que
nature j'ai tu d'affaires le tipi devait
jamais été sur place était jamais allé
moi-même j'ai joué à l'université compte
certains gars qui ont percé des
roadsters puis même le tout effectué ce
qui est une espèce d'image de ce que
c'est fait que toute la nuit
l'étude à profit comme trop jeune homme
faisait là comme les tests physiques les
plus importants de ma carrière mais je
peux dormir avec ses 35 ans plus mais à
new york y avait une drôle de fleurs
j'ai atterri puis un but qui m'attendait
avec petit costaud
le kit une pancarte monsieur boulistes
en limousine question ils m'ont écarté
un cheval blanc il voit une plus grande
valeur dans le j'arrive le lendemain je
sais pas de quoi on va avoir le portrait
de desks pas je suis le seul joueur
aurait lui fait qu'ils me font une
espèce de wockhardt d'abord ils m'ont
brûlé la fin je voyais double tai chi il
m'a fait contre sur plus en fait le
deuxième qui était myton album vient me
rejoindre
il y avait comme 6 go pour m'évaluer le
string coach il y avait le côté débits
le scalp qui m'a amené qui s'appelle
brooks en deux langues est rendue jihem
à edmonton
la couche de débit je mange les dit
qu'il y avait une coupe de monde dont le
dgi m
l'espèce de go que tu veux que tu aimes
ça qu'ils vont donner contre c'est lui
qui fait le papier mais celui de city
puis à la fin je finis j'ai vraiment
bien performé je crois qu'à 37 sur 40
verges qui c'est quoi les gens de terre
c'est la course mais beaucoup d'agilité
bien sûr de ça ils vont évaluer avec des
mouvements qui vont répéter ce que tu
ferais un match avec moi ces courses
arrière transition attraper des ballons
des trucs comme ça ben je non nobel
chalet tenace et pour celles qui se
transpose ses biens départ mathieu a mis
son produit et il faisait de bien
performer au bhv est ce que c'était et
cela soit abonné une 14 qu'il lui c'est
un bon joueur de football ou même pas ce
que c'est indiqué le potentiel métier me
tend un but bête on comprend la vitesse
aussi cités moi je suis considère que
j'avais une vitesse de traque et une
vitesse de game game speed métaux dégage
en ai vu le dga arriver avec des espèces
de cv des track and field extraordinaire
game aguets montcourt peau comme ceux ci
dessus à droite qu'à gauche péter mieux
de regarder à droite et à gauche parce
que le monde sans vie de tous bords tous
côtés mois usain bolt serait pas
nécessairement bon foot puisse pop est
une des marques et est capable de très
près à son segment rendu chez les pros
nfl cfr n'importe qui capable d'attraper
un ballon quand tu es tout seul dans son
ballon pour le propulser sur les test
capable d'attraper un ballon pendant
qu'ils courent par leur tu regardes
parle de trop c'est inévitable d'europol
ballon seul au maximum avant de faire
cogner fait que ton -37 le tea party
copeaux librement oural ballon le
feeling qu'il ya trois gros gars qui
court après pour têtards achat tandis
que j'aimais ce jour la défense parce
que moi je te d'être aussi
avec ce qu'est le web car tout s'est
bien passé puis à la fin mike tannenbaum
est venu devant moi puis il ya dix ans
quand pêche pourrait déménager fait que
j'ai dit je reste ici je fais monstres
comme un état de fait qui a dit parfait
avec l'étape 2 c'était d'aller voir les
médecins de l'équipe était le seul autre
réalise à quel point on d'argent il
m'emmène dans une clinique privée est
évidemment pas d'attentes
c'était le seul et il faut passer des
rayons x pdm oreilles partout test dès
février deux sens avant de toucher de
guînes et là je sais pas combien d'amis
à lyon tout le portrait sortie fait que
qui legayic ligne le groupe que ce qui
s'est passé ton poignet je m'étais cassé
le poignet en 2006 occupe se rétablit
parfois on fait une coupe de tess partie
comme cech la machine est dessus enfin
ce que j'achète de sa voiture me lâcher
en cours de route c'était vraiment un
produit pièces à changer la pile après
cela le chauffeur me conduisait à l'air
ou pas pour mais revenez puis le jir sur
l'appel que zizou était temps c'est
l'assistant du jam qui me dit yens 1
contre pour tous survie riba fait que je
reviens le super gros des taux par
rapport à la gestion de ma carrière en
f1 j'ai une décision havre il ya ba flou
avec qui on parle depuis deux jours qui
samedi qui vont m'offrir de quoi je
viens une fois les jets
il me reste une faute trois haltes à
faire quelqu'un peut-être de posé et
réfléchi va peut-être faire les 9 4 pour
ensuite de se dire qu'il ya 15 ans
c'était il ya hocklines puis les jets
parmi les neuf parmi les onze qui m'ont
donné contre eux j'ai un petit peu de
pouvoir de négoce peut peut-être mal et
gatien boni assignation mais il ya aussi
la chance que pendant que tu fais tes 9
à faire vibrer jet servir d'abord pays
et c'est un autre groupe font comment
finalement on aime mieux john smit et
puis moi je teins jeu t'inquiète je le
suis encore dans l'âme d'enfant sur tout
ce que je veux dans ma vie c'est une
opportunité avec jerry prouver la nfl
encore j'ai deux bonnes saisons recrue
de l'année dans ces fnb
je vois canadian à domicile mais sa
transe pour vous auriez laisse rien
présager pour la scientifique
j'ai pris l'opportunité ça a même étudié
le portrait de qui sont les débits dans
l'équipe quels sont les besoins pour le
job que cette équipe qui comme
normalement j'aurais peut-être pris le
temps de tout réfléchir ce piège dans
une équipe où le saviez touch it votre
c'est une équipe où les débits sont
poche parce que ça va te mettre en
valeur mais en même temps tu sais très
bien qu jazz qui vont aller repêcher
deux gosses première ronde c'est
deuxième ronde
mais pour ce que j'ai sauté à pieds
joints dans l'aventuré à new york j'ai
déménagé la semaine suivante
c'est ce genre de truc qui est enfin à
imaginer comme raccroché le téléphone
non mais je continue merci je vous
reviens comme si une fois qu il est vrai
mais j'ai rêvé toute ma vie de ce j'ai
rêvé de la cfmj rêver de montréal mais
c'est là en effet pissos sais que j'ai
encore des gens comme mon contrat encore
dry à la maison ça c'était ça peut durer
aussi longtemps que j'aurais voulu mais
je vraiment faire de cette période
c'était une erreur ce n'est pas que
j'avais c'est en 2008 que ça fait onze
ans avec le ce contre le ce contrôleur
sans ma quoi les loups être d'entrée ce
soit parce que j'avais pas de pouvoir de
négoce avait rien prouvé fait le con tre
minimum c295 ni dans la vie où s affiche
les prophètes au groupe les 9 mois puis
j'arrivais d'un salades les canadiennes
et hyman zaho comment ça les canadiens
tu peux très bien gagner ma vie
maintenant surtout quand tu arrives
comme canadien recruter pays comme la
main les américains au début sont payés
plus cher mais quand est un canadien et
que tu es bon et que tu performes au
dessus de la moyenne
le tu peux demander cher parce que le
produit canadien de qualité erreur fait
que mon année recrue
on m'a offert trente neuf mille dollars
39 milliards pour 8 pour 1 pour arrêter
faire toutes leurs songes il dit jeudi
c'était soit 39 erreur pour un an ou
deux à 41,43 j'ai pris le 2 de l'eau
pourquoi j'ai pas après mon année recrue
plus de ceux de les signer avec les 8-15
fait que sauf que cette fois grâce à mes
performances aux honneurs que j'ai gagné
se faisait des bonis puis les play-offs
au 6 août aps été payés supplémentaires
fake raflé les deux premières années
j'ai fait en 75 et 80 mm dans le hall de
la ligue canadienne j'imagine
ah non pas en tenant compte en fait
c'est là que c'est c'est le tarif comme
un kit dit comme moi tout ce que je veux
je m'en fous du prix joue faux je joue
au front mais pragmatique comparé à qui
il ya un tel là bas il ya bande marzouki
qui jouaient pour vancouver lieu de
partage et aux vétérans aguerris mais
comme ma deuxième année le jeu partage
vraiment bons domaines dans lesquels tu
dis que moi qui lui fait comme 200000 le
moi j'en fais comme 40 trop fixe le fait
que tu commences à te coupera plus ça
devient plus frustré moi je me suis dit
moi j'aurai du faire soi même tête de
poche au foot embarque dans cette phase
il faut que ça a été ça mon début parce
que je participe en effet la peau sont
survenues le j'avais dû voir 2
des négos puis j'ai demandé la totale en
effet caire ça a été payant
on a boat l1 puis c'est quoi le la la
différence entre les qualités de jeu
parce que moi mettons je regarde d'un
point de vue extérieur puis on dirait
que ces deux mondes complètement
différents titres game et on m'a laissé
sur sa carrière finie en queue de
poisson même c'est pas fini mais
maintenant jhonny menzel et qui est dans
la nfl qui étant un bon quart arrière
initialement avant que ça parte en
couilles mais qui vient après c'est que
les alouettes puis quelqu'un tu as
l'impression qu'ils décident de partir à
course qui a personne qui peut le
toucher
moi si tu as l'impression que si je suis
imbattable
la game est effectivement très très
différentes par la nature m'a dit qu'ils
étaient indifférents les ballons à
limiter le ballon et différents ballons
j'ai fait les plus grosses france ou qui
peut-être moins faciles à attraper mais
pas facile a lancé m mais on a des
terrains plus petits un joueur de moins
en effet un essai de plus surtout le lan
url dans les dimensions du terrain
il laissait de plus à faire en sorte que
tout ton jeu au sol peut être un peu
plus varier les angles poursuite aussi
que les actes d' attaques sont
différents c'est un game est un petit
peu plus physique
à ce niveau là si flc plus wide open
c'est flamboyance extraordinaire les
trois essais font en sorte que t'as pas
le choix d'avoir un jeu qui est taxé un
jeu offensif axée sur la page
les transitions de ballons aussi les
beautés rendre sur bénéfice d'un mais
c'est qu'en fait tu peux pas comparer je
te donne un exemple de linebacker
serveurs extérieurs la nfl avec un
horaire lambert que de laisser fait de
savoir comment ces succès à chier dans
ses effets parce que le pays pèse 230 5
248 lui il en pèse 190 millions pas les
mêmes
oui quoi le même mandat dans ce sens où
elle stagne en bas que de la nfl voir sa
vie plus sain dit line un john bowman de
ce monde de la cfl fait qu'à ce niveau
là c'est dur à comparer mais moi ce que
j'ai remarqué une fois là bas ce qui est
pas un choix
un but que j'ai côtoyés nancy eiffel qui
aurait l'air fou
dans un camp d'entraînement nfl que la
nuance et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant c'est que les cinq ses
superstars que tu connais dans chaque
équipe nfl ce sont des machines
ils sont intelligents ils ont
l'expérience ils sont forts comme des
brutes ont tout et le talent et le
potentiel et les tic et les autres go en
dessous c'est tout du monde
interchangeables puis quand tu regarde
le portrait des paiements aussi de
salaire ces cinq six gallois qui vont
faire le gros du cash ce cap salarial
puis les autres si j'exagère mais ce que
je vois des petits comme moi qui ont le
minimum puisque aucun qui commence à
être moyen on souhaite se bat saint leu
leu il y en a du roulement leucate
trouve-t-on des mouches études m'ont
fait qu au niveau de sa lettre à la fota
qui font comme entre les deux les
patriots est la meilleur exemple de 184
gueule qui font un gros salaire puis
après c'est un nouveau while aussi
chacun qu'ils ne le parlent leur système
est phénoménal puisse à terme de
transposer en compagnie de n'importe
quoi d'autre la ion sont bâtis de
mentalité puis des steak tweets et puis
parce que j'aime surtout de leur affaire
c'est que un gosse blesse alors que
plein d'équipés panique qui veulent
aller chercher sur le marché des joueurs
autonomes aux autres il donne tu es dans
l'équipe des pâtes c'était le quatrième
sa liste
s'il y en a trop qui se blesse c'est toi
qui vois un bateau qui va attraper le
ballon
c'est exactement les gosses ont prêté
jusqu'à octobre et 10 été suspendu
quatre matches pour la fin des ballons
dégonflés
mais l'autre giacobbi bleus si tu t'es
pris sa place il ya gagné le lui s'est
blessé de guerre apollo ou peut-être
celle inverse entre le iiième cube il
sait sa grossesse était 3e puis il gagne
encore avec lui type légaux ont été là
encore une fois ils ont été patients
mais il connaît ce système lui toujours
interchanger tout le monde combien une
fois c'est lui la star de l'équipe hugo
ni comme un salaire qui peut gagner des
sous
amen et j'écoute quand je tape aux
alouettes
je gagne 39 mille dollars ouais j'ai
anthony calvillo côté de moi qui fais
pour ma 450 mais elle ne trouvait que
c'est un monde de différence première
semaine j'arrive au jet ce site avec un
driver ce qui a été
achetez première ronde qui a fini sa son
contrat de recrue qui t'a pas le plus
créatif apprécié son contrat de 100
millions ils la jouent conditions on
sort à new york
les grecs avaient accepté des fêtes
chars moi j'ai signé 295
mais ce même un le gpo fait d'argent
quand je vais pas de comptes ouverts
j'ai pas encore je peux encore la banque
fait que j'ai produit un point de dépôt
direct encore tous leurs produits ton
spécieux que j'arrive avec mon 41000 de
la saison précédente et l'on sort à new
york
toutes les autres calculs poule
maintenant je dois arriver s'il a fait 6
millions sans sa première année c'était
un conteur son contrôle incrusté 36
millions pour chevaux fait que les
causes achètent des bouteilles de
champagne tout essence l'hymen j'ai
acheté comme une bouteille de vote que j
ai proposé comme un sens en place puis
mon coeur me regarder comme une merde
est parfait mais ça pour dire que comme
le j'avais encore envie mon salaire de
46 41 48 puis lui 6 millions 6 millions
le faisait par games le jeu c'est comme
360 dollars la semaine dépassé 360 mais
voilà mais mon point ses suivants charte
avec les autres j'ai réalisé que est
cependant game en vie après ce pendant
la saison les samedis march of tu peux
rentrer et entraîné moi je le faisais
mais si une coupe de fin de semaine par
mois tu as envie de partir en camping ou
met au tapis par carte à dubaï sharjah
ils ne lisent un avion puis savons faire
le party comme avait guère souri nolisé
un avion faire le protêt miami
terriblement des bolides juillet dessus
des yeux d'orgueilleux fait que je fais
comme quoi rien pour l'avion comme nous
l'avions 70 watts quoi j'aime rendez
vous s'annonce fabuleux
ouais je te pose est ce qu'elle est ce
que les parias les séparent telle jamais
non alors je les portais new york oui
oui puisque est génial en plus c'est que
l'équipe puisque je trouve ça
extraordinaire à quel point il pense à
toute l'équipe a engagé un service de
chauffeur de voiture des chèques pour
porte les gars c'est bon on conduit jim
rice a fait chier c'est l'équipe qui
paye c'est mal le seul problème c'est
qu'il faut que tu donnes ton nom fait
que ce qu'on faisait c'est qu'on va rien
c'est comme une fête semaine symbolique
d'un dollar contre des chauffeurs les
les bruins de boston
cave agoria coupe stanley la dernière
fois il y avait une photo qui avaient
circulé sur internet c'était le tape du
bord j'étais payée par l'équipe c'était
genre 750 jeudi qu'un bon open qui gère
avec tout le monde en place puis mettez
ça sur le compte de l'équipe 750000 une
soirée que matt jean le baril devait
même pas avoir assez de bouteille pour
cette phase est parfait relais pour les
corridas sont partis mais a fait bâton
ce ont ce recul
sept cent cinquante mille dollars c'est
beaucoup d'argent l'argent gagné
l'argent de restaurants de bars que tu
dépenses sur le reverront plus jamais
non wen investissement walchi après
demain ou après-demain dans l'examen
annoncé fou mais moi je m'habille aux
gens parlent plus on est sorti d'une des
premières semaines dans un restaurant
qui s'appelait y aspirent restera je
pense existe plus mais c'était surtout
un petit coin dirais qu'on est au près
une dizaine de gars pythie aux states le
cap sur son mobile afin de soir au resto
il tombe à pic et bill faux dilemme est
notamment pisté km à 14 15 mètres pièce
où je me suis appuyé mais c'est beaucoup
plus de souplesse et combien on est un
fils je t'aime est arrivé saleh sa
casquette lui dise ok cartes de crédit
fec
je veux tout le monde comme près ça car
cela qui fait le buzz comme cochons pour
sa remise
j'ai des accès l'aéroport fès mais seul
le smatah limite des crédits soit
caniculaire massif et tu peux le faire
de toutes sortes de façons pour le
faisait aux alouettes aussi mais c'est
comme pour prendre le ton un jeu ps3
sapiens est un gamin m faites-le il pige
c'est le dernier la dernière 4 qui reste
qu'il annonce le billet le conflit moi
j'ai aucun et stikeman parce que même si
je pige et à passeport ou la carte j'ai
pas 15 milieu où est ma carte
maintenant que j'ai ce avec 1000
canadien fait que je me disais que j'ai
ma carte de guichet jeu peu d'argent le
diamant le ch fait cocasse à chaque fois
cap pour ton ami ceni si mal et la
mission viens poster métro l'a testé
radio.com la j'appelle mon pare de noir
reste au nom des principes à tout le
monde rit genre en tirant les cartes
etienne qui je te jure je te rendre
blind j'ai été pigée comme 4e 3e avant
dernier je suis seul je célébrais
quelqu'un d'autre l'a payé présenté
comme business as usual suisse apporte
même temps ils prennent pas des super
bonnes habitudes pour la cité jaurès et
non pas la manche mais j'ai vécu ces
moments là c'est qu'en fait mais
t'imagines t'imagines si j'appelle mon
père oui mais le tout reste au à ma
carte pense pas qu'ils aient cormicy
cormier comme 11 quand suffit de poule
j'espère être jamais rendu comme
j'espère avoir les reins assez solides
financièrement pour être capable de
payer un bill de 15000 mais j'espère pas
être le grand frère mais je m legault
comme multi millionnaire comme non c'est
peut-être le tableau
sap a de bons sets il ya tellement des
choses mais vaccins j'en ai besoin
j'ai entendu ces histoires là c'était je
pense j'écoutais un podcast qui
s'appelle spitting check weight loss qui
parle de rock et tout le temps puis les
guenilles ont joué dans la ligue b il
parle de des chemins raconte des
histoires de c puis on les invités
plaire ce vin que derek stepan qui avait
joué avec marian gaborik dans le temps
que marian gaborik visite des grosses
erreurs bizet il y avait personne qui
paient rien après les gains s'étaient
égarés qui se tapaient c'était comme
tout le monde j'ai enfin bielby jeu mais
en coulisses jean c'était lui
travaillait ce genre il ya un mois qui
faisait comme u millions par année puis
comme c'était en même temps c'est pas
glop de importe c'est quand l'argent est
ce parce que quand l'argent vaut purent
rien bruel tiges octobre et 10 y a plus
besoin de gens là il y aura jamais de
problème financier via une différence
entre gawler puis un gars qui fait 2 3
millions pendant quatre mois si c'est
oui c'est ça c'est ce qu'il y ait comme
sournois du sport professionnel puis de
la vie en général aussi comme tu réussis
atteint d'un salaire que tu désires tu
mairie puis l'autre commence à calculer
qui le jettent rantissi the supremes ma
retraite à 65 ans
j'ai 29 ans à la fac kenwright les
choses changent
fake fota profitent pendant que ça parle
ça jamais savoir ça va revenir l'année
suivante il qu'il y en a qui se plaint
pas j'ai vu des gars mon coloc quand
j'étais à new york est atteint mais
comme on le salue mais comme lui a joué
il ya fait un peu le même parcours que
moi y est parti à mi saison des
alouettes l'année d'avant puis je jouais
des game la moitié de la saison avec les
jets
la fin de saison là il s'est acheté une
benz est d'acheter les logs louis
vuitton east acheter des souliers en
apnée
puis c'est quoi il s'est fait couper
rendu au mois de mars
puis quand je t'ai
j'ai été coupé momodou sa benne était
encore dans le parking des jays parce
qu'avec une scène pour aller la chercher
comme si des timbres et des evil dct tu
peux ne plus travailler un jour d'été
jours puis tu vas garder le rythme des
victoires jusqu'à la fin 2010 c'est son
argent déjà investi je sais c'est en
fait les enfants commencent à dépenser
mais surtout au football et aucune
garantie de rien si c'est fou comme les
10 par un but c'était c'était ça c'est
sa blonde faisait un plus gros salaire
il va rester avec jack et locke temps
par capote jay-z beyoncé comme ok
laquelle il pleuvait plus on le sait
même pas où il mettait au fond ce qu'ils
veulent
oui c'est exact n'ont pas pas la face
comme toptable emmène tout à l'échelle 1
les quatre vies mais ne s'est pas
retirée après ceux de s'adapter pour
vivre une émotion forte le ce a protesté
aujourd'hui qu'elle fait un barbecue
chez vous le territoire plus à espérer
mais ma vie et mieux maintenant je suis
content de l'avoir vécue et je peux dire
que je les fait mais j'ai vécu plein
d'affaires aussi dans ma carrière pro
soit testé pour les stéroïdes
c'est weird en tabarnouche en dessous et
c'est drôle nfl première journée
première journée le j'arrive après moi
ma première pratique
je veux juste comme ça et puis je fais
une sieste téléphone desjardins choqué
les états américains oui allô a essayé
en l2
l affaire du testing une voiture devant
chez vous qui attend vous avez 24 heures
pour vous rapporter aux caisses et n
importe qui ont fait leurs gammes
ouais mais llodra qui avec un bonhomme
le jul skywilly test effectué 24 arrêts
je fais que j'ai fait rentrer évidemment
aucun charisme legrand taxer petite
mallette ficus comment ça marche avec
les mêmes end en salles de bain c'est
oui avec un humain que tu connais pas ou
qui voit un faux qui voit le sortir
bennis qui doit faire pipi ne peut pas
aller de cacher fait non seulement ce
faux-pas lève ton t-shirt avec les tas
de chaises devant l'autre focus based et
pantalon et et culottes en dessous des
genoux et qu'il faut vraiment que cech
la grande île doit avoir un visuel sera
examinée après ça tu étais comme ce fait
que c'est vraiment un malaise en plus il
veut t'aider fait il par le robinet et
floch la manie comme il commença par les
blessures comme doute pas me concentrer
à faire c'est drôle parce que lui
imagine mais lui c'est ça aussi la vie
lui rendre sa femme et j'ai fait les
jets jersic j'ai vu rouler bouler
précédente et mériterait pas il faut pas
s'attendre à ce don des pénis ses galons
dans la journée des pénis qui font pipi
c'était pas son rêve qu'inquiéter quitté
le port cros qui s'épanouit comme
présenté à travers la nfl
il regarde on sent pas autant cette
répression financière mais fixe à
souhait j'ai différenciée comme trois
quatre fois pendant mes neuf mois là bas
c'est weird à tavannes ne peux pas
croire c'est comme du rap au bureau
serait pour cgi jean martin et des
hautois la demande et ouais adaptons
chandelle
il n'y a pas d'autres jobs qui peuvent
se permettre de vivre de conneries
bonne job qui est permettant tifa une
journée à la job avec papale j'espère
qu'ils seraient évités dans la classe de
son fils bonjour mon nom est maintenant
je vous ai fait le top dix groupes ou
les nombreux avec un look un ange et
geneviève cantin qui était une
dangereuse avec les talentueux spiky qui
était sur l'équipe nationale fait qu
elle pouvait se faire tester comme ça
mais un nom étant les et c'est déjà
mieux par le pacifique puis a fait une
épreuve de 200 4 nages ainsi colas en
finale mais c'est parce qu'on est
probable sont des provinces et le
lendemain c'est l'épreuve ce qui a le
plus de chances de se classer mais a
fait la finale aux 200 4 nages la veille
puis quand ça fonctionne avec 204 6 à 4
pl dans l'oeuf entier commence à
fonctionner pour les tests dans ces
affaires là c'est si tu gagnes tu
traiter ce thème puis au hasard dans les
sept autres finalistes taponier deux
noms est là elle est arrivée quand même
4e 5e mais on se fait prendre que pilote
c'est ok j'ai lu à focale épicé après
les finales
sauf que là et pourquoi pas et progrès
n'est pas capable de vent l'a fait
depuis ses as claque de l'eau est pas
capable
son épreuve et le lendemain et pokhara
de pisser jusqu'à minuit mais n'ont fait
que leur aecon a piscine encore à
attendre de faire les tests agissent
pour être capable de pousser
évidemment je pense que les pilotes ne
postulerait de warwick non mais dans le
fond le biais y attendait à aller
j'espère qu'il est en cap et sportives
aux pistes flamand a réussi à dissiper
elle ne pas super à rien c'est pile à
l'arrivée à l'hôtel legends rue nord de
la nuit' son épreuve c'est le lendemain
à 8 heures
puis le joueur avait plus comme ans
avait été la même histoire s'est
terminée mais comme nous arrêter à
l'hôtel puis on attendait juste comme on
entendait dire ouais je n'y avais époque
a dit c est pas parvenu à l'hôtel encore
est-ce que c'était cela c'est vraiment
juste stéroïdes mettons cette fumée du
poteau il y avait deux sortes de tests
à l'époque la en 2008 il y avait des
tests qui étaient dirigés qui peut
améliorer la performance
puis l'autre d'autres trucs drogue puis
c'est comme deux trucs les paniers ses
poignets pour récréatif le montat de
colloques mais deux fait que je n'aime
pas lequel mais lui potter c'est vrai
puis toujours gelé la manne et la façon
que c'est réglé piste est comme ça aussi
d'anciens fait longtemps qu'il a si elle
allait plus loin faisait des tests
sanguins
c'est pour je passais des hormones de
croissance qui peuvent n'apparaît pas
dans l'uriné tout à perdre en soi mais
une fois qu'ils peignent un coup que ce
soit stéroïdes ou what would have heures
tout comme une place dans ce sens où
dort pas de suspension l'équipe sera pas
mise au courant on répète quand tu
entends parler que tu ailles voir là
l'effet se fait prendre
puis suspendu deux matches c'est en fait
sa deuxième fouet qui se fait prendre
fake mais leighton flag amnesty fait
clouzot qu'un que s'est fait prendre
le pote le moment job de mon body nfl
qui faisait les tests n'étaient pas
quitte ma maison après chaque prêtre a
well peter and test fait les leçons du
drame a ciblé mais c'est sur le premier
coûte comme un espèce de passe droit de
cesser le gueut l'apprécient connaissait
sa graine
[Rires]
et je sais pas si tu sais tu es là
rapporte cette question estimant par
léopold mais c'est quoi la culture des
drogues de performance dans le football
parce que j'ai pu j'ai entendu des
affaires le cas mais pour passer au
prochain steps et des zèbres surtout qu
au corps le de stéroïdes bâti je pense
que pendant ce temps-là espèce de drogue
de choix que tu en avais parlé dans tout
l'espace des stéroïdes
puis après se sert comme bouger aux
hormones de croissance je pensais était
se populariser avec le cyclisme a dit le
foot ça c'est drogba cfl haut débit
avait pas de tests mes premières années
la manie avec l'association des joueurs
on a voté pour ne travailler fort pour
instaurer un système de jack testing
qu'on voulait que soient le mieux que
toutes les autres x il que et le nombre
de go qui ont pris leur retraite
enfin la teuf c'était phénoménal
puis il ya personne qui parle de ce mois
ci soleil un peu comme église était
capable de réaliser que maintenant un
cockpit de la saison faute est tellement
longue et elle même à gagny que tu vas
commencer la saison que les trapèzes
domaine vaincre acquis par manet de
pulte entraîneur parce que c'est que du
maintien mais le semaines thomas là une
épaule si ce fait tu vas perdre un peu
de masse au cours d'une saison de foot
80 cockpit qui lui on gagne de m pose
des questions mais mais c'est pas
quelque chose que dans dont on parle
c'est pas parler beaucoup dans
l'appentis tu regardes mettons et
justement les le mvp du dernier super
bowl julian edelman qui commence la
saison avec comme trois ou quatre
matches de suspension pour drogues de
performance puis eddy jamais quelle il
dit jamais laquelle peut y arrive au
super bowl puis le gars parce que comme
tu dis c'est du maintien n'était pas le
temps d'aller faire du cardio de portal
2 il est audible le guet iarivo super
bowl man
les estives deyn qui sortent chaque top
les trapèzes bas gonflés puis le gars il
s'est fait suspendre en début de saison
pour ceux qui arrivent au super bowl you
l'air d'un animal sorti de l'axé comme
fois qu'ils menèrent freeman grâce à
bientôt type qui pose la question à
savoir des fois c'est une game 2 qui est
capable ce qui est la meilleure équipe
médicale dans la foulée bakhit s'est en
fait c'étaient ceux avec qui je parle
d'un cyclisme j'ai raconté cyclisme
était mou ce que j'ai entendu donc on va
peut-être que je parle à travers mon
chapeau mais si tu veux juste faire
partie de l'équipe qui va aller au tour
de france tout comme pas le choix d'être
sur le ep haut parce que sinon beau à
forces égales en citant le nom sera le
seul sait ce qu'on a su par la force de
l'homme est maintenant profond manque ça
ne pas changer ben moi j'ai l'impression
parce que les scientifiques qui se
battront des scientifiques titre sonne
comme ce petit premièrement l'effort à
la base et sûrement de faire pipi quand
c'est rendu que entre les leur
compétition
ils se font faire des tic retirer le ca
pour leur est exigé pour leur remettre
dans le thé rendu ailleurs dans ton
espèce de type de compétitions sportives
exact c'est clair mais en même temps
c'est ça ça devient par les autres c'est
une question qui est tellement totché
parce que tu as tu arriveras jamais tout
ça ça n'ira jamais non parce que le
besoin de se qualifier l'espèce de rêve
que tous ses caisses que le risque que
tu pourras à face
le jour où tu réalises que tu auras
besoin de tout ce qu'on peut donner que
les aurains y arrive torte toute ta vie
tout entraîné tu es et tu es bon tu est
assidu de discipline et de fait tout ce
qu'il fallait pour que ça marche
peux tu arrive à un point où est ce que
comme telle qui manque juste à faire ce
lien quasi parce qu'ils sont toutes là
dessus puis tu fais ci est ce que je
reste là je pose la question à
l'université je me suis posé la question
parce que j'avais entendu qu'un bon
chama mois
avait commencé à l'emprunt mais en fait
certes été l'exemple parfait pour ça
parce que tu étais à souhaite percer
l'alignement tête à ça de faire une
longue carrière en effet l'effectif dit
à barnet mais c'est ça m'aurait donné
quoi de plus j'aurais banshee 3,4 de
plus à 2,25
j'aurais peut-être cours et un petit peu
plus vite j'aurais été plus fort ce
terrain maule où je me suis posé la
question à l'université c'est comme j'ai
vu ce gars-là aller pisser il sait tout
démantibulé cpt des ligaments c'est
comme ça encore de bréhat de surplus moi
ça m'a fait comme auchan non mais je me
suis dit tac je n'ai pas besoin de ce
parce que ma carrière a toujours fait
seulement tant que j'en ai pas besoin
j'irai pol pot ale le parlement que
penses-tu que dans la nfl ou dans le
football il ya vraiment sérieusement
checker avec le mcs voulons ce que
j'aime avec encore des spas ou est ce
que tu dis comme ça c'est toléré en été
mais en fait c'est petit c'est très très
checker médecins partent c'est drôle
parce que non ce pécule mais c'est à
partir du moment où tu te fais prendre
une fois puis que c'est pas su c'est
comme ça donne peut-être l'opportunité
de repartir et plus intelligemment c'est
de faire comme à spa ce que j'aime être
calculée dans mon calendrier le texte
engage un geste pas un médecin qui tarde
c'est comme si ça donne une passe droit
de punir
est ce qu'ils veulent vraiment enrayer
ce je pense que oui mais en même temps
c'est toujours super 4 euros la nfl ils
veulent voir des gosses taper sa gueule
c'est les joueurs étoiles sont
disqualifiés dans ma tête je regarde ce
qu'ils ont fait aux yeux fc avec jon
jones comme sa cote est bon ça se fait
six fois qui se fait c'est comme deux
jours ou une semaine avant le combo il
ya quelques quelques années ou quelques
mois il se fait reprendre à corps et le
yuv si au lieu de prendre position en
direct ça va faire mon âme maintenant
parce qu'il ramène de l'argent il change
d'état il change le gala au lieu de les
médias en californie il l'amène ailleurs
où la drogue qui a pris elle est légale
le fake comme à quel point tu donne une
chance au coeur parce qu'en plus
évidemment c'était 7 à vache à lait
c'est le seul dans cette espèce de
division le qui fait de l'argent qui est
pas plus atypiques comme suspect correct
séparent ils prennent le temps que ça
dérange pas assez le monde qui regarde
ce qu on fait tout comme juge à la
performance qui est faite au super bowl
c'était complètement à la trappe et des
balles a dit le stéroïde la laitue
vraiment à mieux attraper le ballon
non ça les problèmes à mieux se
positionner pièces des voix dont avec
leurs invités par mail à la jolie
carrière
les gens veulent voir des liens sont
trop basses et ça les gens écoutent
écouter tour de france pour ceux qui
veut pas tout ce qui a fait en dehors du
sport c'est que le sait il le fait grâce
à sa mêlée mais lui c'en est un qui
était puni de c'est par exemple ce
barman qui a payé pour ça comme l'examen
s'étendrait qui en a d'autres qui ont
des noms plus facile parce que
j'écoutais un ryu barque d'un cycliste
qui commentait le tour de france puis il
sait que ses commentaires vidéos de
chris froome qui en fait c'est le giro
d'italie chris froome qui attaquent à 81
kg de la fin puis qui sera jusqu'au bout
de soldes speed êtes vous regardez le
cyclisme eddy tout le monde qui chialent
sur le document cyclisme vous écoutez si
le tour de france pour pourvoir un gars
comme moi n'a monté un qu'elle vous
l'écoutez pourvoir desagneaux complète
et du fric génétique ce qu'on aime c'est
ce qu'ils font à mortrée fait clair dit
à quel point ce sport là sont prêts à
enlever sur pour enlever le show
l'éthique c'est comme jusqu'où ils
peuvent pousser la note ça se faire
taper dessus qu'ils prennent pas soin de
la santé de leurs athlètes
ceux qui n'ont pas même partout métier
permet définitivement
le pays est une série de documentaires
sur deux dirigeants sont justement t
comcast est ouverte
et puis les gars y expliquait était le
père du prince fuite montre l'école pied
au lieu d'avoir les jambes qui brûle
depuis des des deux comme les baltes et
ses ravages s'accumulent pour montants
coll mais c'est parce qu'ils prennent
sens d'entraînement avec imagine comment
tu peux pousser en entraînement si
l'acide lactique embarque pomme qui peut
établir l art il lui prépare it et
muscles sont comme un morceau même
rythme souviennent de ce mets pour vrai
tu dois mal dormir le soir en
tabarnouche pascal ruiz a comme il faut
petit quand cela paye par tabarouette
dans cette espèce de gestion le petit si
je me fais prendre tout mon genre tout
s'écroule dès fois il fallait qu'ils se
lèvent d'ennuis pour importer danic
parce que le bo s'est ralentie ton la
circulation sanguine dans ton corps fait
que ça un message qui s'adresse des
caillots pics à bloc
le club se mettaient des cadres à se
lever c'est dangereux il devait leur
peau mais y'a plein mondial philippines
et en font une très longue qui
manqueraient ailleurs il ya un an genre
des lots en argent norvégien ils étaient
en camp d'entraînement
il mord dans douche caillot de sang le
sait comme un oeil humain comme un
malaise normal c'est normal guette un
camp d'entraînement je pense qu'il peut
même pas se poser à être le seul os qui
avait dit quelques vérités comme un camp
d'entraînement poway ce qu'il avait dit
ker puis ils mordent en douche mais d'un
caillot sanguin tu vois pas quelle fin
atroce mais c'est ça aussi c'est que
l'état santé ou si tu en voilà des
anciens athlètes le critique à mourir à
35 40 ans
les lutteurs tic tac protesté le sait
non je vais c'est quand même quand tu
peux t'offrir d'une crise de coeur à 38
ans tétraplégique et liberté quand il
fait beau je voulais qu'on parle un peu
con seulement un peu de sport le jeu
l'est qu'on parle de de la croisière du
naufrage
les naufragés de la route s'élève à
animer la deuxième saison ben ali mais à
première c'est quoi cette expérience à
canal vie évidemment j'ai pas la case
horaire c'est télé réalité avec skil
concept une télé réalité où on regroupe
des parents célibataires avec la fin par
un navire pendant une croisière dans le
but d'essayer de former des familles
recomposées fait que c'est comme
l'occupation audoubert si on attend on
est impatient de commencer maintenant
que ça serait une scène d'abord jardé
des divorcés 45 ans montant qui fonce je
le quitte en bisbille à voter messieurs
non parce que c'est un fait c'est canal
vie ont fait que c'est plus clean clean
c'est plus clean aussi pas juste parce
que c'est ce canal 10 parce que 10 ans
afin d'impliquer ces faits que l'on veut
c'est pas de l'amour le nom qu il n est
pas sûr que ça prenne le nous mais en
fait c'est vraiment cool j'ai tripé
parce que j'ai connecté aussi avec les
candidats et candidates c'est du monde
avec ses épaules tout le monde notre
quad il y arrive aussi avec un bagage
qu'une expérience de veepee les pères
célibataires moi je me suis divorcé une
fois en piste et oui je connus que ça
peut peut-être pour devrait permettre de
rencontrer plus facilement 400 mais
c'est monsieur madame tout le monde
divorce de 1,6 éprouvant émotivement
financièrement encore et encore mon
estime
est-ce que c'est entre la gestion des
enfants de réorienter tic comme se
trouve une maison qui peut importe
retomber sur ses pieds apprécions
émotivement psychologiquement comment tu
fais pour rencontrer quelqu'un dans ce
test pilot study quand même j'ai des
enfants j'ai deux trois enfants un
enfant peut pas comme quelqu'un auquel
filles qui vont être intéressés à comme
devenu belmihoub comme on dirait que je
pose super intéressant le toughbook geof
pas qui combat le président se dit bon
je vois aller voir facebook si je vais
aller voir tes deux jours par le
magazine comme swype wright puis un
pollock ce vote engagé quelque chose de
super série fait non c'est pour dire
qu'on a comme tout mis ensemble les
paramètres pour que ça fonctionne peut
évidemment un gros trip par rapport aux
15,2 candidat qui peut chuter avec qui
puis il ya des twists un peu dans cette
émission là aussi mais il ya un gros tri
d'enfants vous avez déjà une idée des
ainsi qu'aux les matchs possible mais
évidemment tu veux prendre déjà qu'ils
vont tu crois avoir des affinités vont
bien s'entendre aussi c'est quoi la
tranche d'âge
je te dirais que c'est pas mal ouvert
mon avis je crois la dernière fois et
par an 30 ans puis 44 45 fait que fox
ares adultes
mais ce poste plus par james post par
non ce n'est pas on n'est pas ça quand à
saint-quentin non plus on serait pas
fermé à ce non plus mais encore une fois
l'esprit d'avoir cédé match enfin on
essaie de rester regroupés dans le même
trajet on essaie aussi de la difficulté
puisque ce qu'on a réalisé après une
saison d'expérience je donne un exemple
les parents qui étaient ce navire avec
des enfants de 10 12 ans ben autre le
soir les enfants pouvaient aller sur ce
coup chez soi les clés d'un arc est de
faire de même plus on pouvait sortir
c'est au reste aussi les enfants les
parents qui ont des enfants 2 3 4 5 1
faut que c'est un autre qu'un tournage
se termine
ben ils vont super pied rentrent à la
chambre ils peuvent pas repartir à
préfecture au niveau de la connexion
fait qu est ce qu on veut aussi
s'arranger pour que ce soient des
enfants du même âge en même temps on
veut pas forcer les choses non plus
parce que ça se peut des matchs ou avec
des enfants que tu jamais fait c'est
toute cette dynamique le qui rase
intéressant c'était un défi de
production saab ont senti j'ai pas
participer ou j'ai pas la meilleure
compréhension d'occupation de métier je
pense pas que vous voyez les filles à
tous les jours je suppose que vous
tournez à tous les jours non plus ce qui
fait que tu un espèce de journée de
tournage
le lendemain matin tu peux avoir ton
meeting pour débriefer ainsi qu en ph
s'intéresse à un tel fait que l'on pour
pas que ça fasse trois vieux sont vos sa
rage que ph and hate avec une hausse
mais nous aurons deux fois sur le soir
même parce que la même année sort pas
bieleu les missions secrètes où le temps
fera musulmans étaient brûlés red meat
is fait comme si c'étaient deux semaines
dans la foule on le voit si on augmente
à 300 pour se donner justement quelques
petites journées pour décanter mais fait
que ce ne sont pas des filles ce test
est mister mystère mais la boxe
l'autre différence aussi par rapport à
vous aussi à la maison de la maison
décrit tout le monde et ce même bateau
fait quand on fini de tourner
littérature comme les feuilles dans
votre coin
l'effectif des fois il se passe
d'affaires of camelot et comme toutes
les oreilles partout petit fait comme
moi on va se parler
ses concepteurs frenchies elle s'est
faite le si ça vous sépariez pas le
monde quand c'était fini mais tu essayes
jaked avec beaucoup de volonté
c'est fou c'est quand quelqu'un qui sait
que le dancehall à qui est-ce qui est
comme ph occupation double des gens qui
trouvent la mort 300 ouais vraiment
c'est plutôt pht un des exemples le
meilleur je pense que renault aussi le
cas non liés aux helvètes plaisir je
pense en tant qu'ensemble sérieusement
de bolivie puis renonce tous des frères
non je me fonde alors les watts est un
des bons exemples de ce pays mais oui
nos feux de l'amour aussi t on quand on
est faite l'espèce de 2 que sont ils
devenus
notre coupe futur était encore ensemble
à ce que cherche le sont encore
maintenant qu'il s'est aussi lié ces
débours liens d'amitié c'est que les
filles seront souvent encore suspenseurs
ils font des activités fait que c'est
devenu des amis que les enfants fassent
côtoient confecta c'est ultra positif
cette expérience je pense aux personnes
qui est sorti de là je pensais vraiment
et je pense pas qu'une personne qui suit
thérapie puis mes autres dodge ram -
préparer au travail de tous et non plus
par la force des choses tant ainsi
côtoyer des moutons contre mais trois
semaines sur une croisière peut-être pas
tout côtoyer des gens qui connaît pas à
manier quelques tapisseries amanites
vaut faire un faux pas pitié cdd longue
journée de tournage aussi c'est ce qui
est drôle c'est tout pour le problème en
témoigner les premières journées tu es
dans ton espèce de personnages c'est
comme moi je veux montrer ce côté de ma
personnalité mais par la force des
choses à man et finit par oublier
deviens toi même c'est là que ça devient
petit bonbon c'est parce qu'elle est
plus faible
ouais c'est clair ça fait se présente
avec un personnage au début tu ne serais
pas un personnage mais jamais un
classique la moelle ap le milieu trois
jours après tête avec des gaz maison qui
dit que ça brasse un peu aussi le titre
perd l'espèce de filtre encore une faute
et brûlé depuis quand il voudra y les
impôts de bronze est affecté comme cat
est fatigué la censure est agitée
la fête qui était pas bien fier c'est
comme que tu dis que j'ai mal géré ce
bouteloup bas j'ai mal géré plusieurs
boules mais de là à dire que non
d'affaires que je ferais différemment
c'est sûr c'était quand même un truc que
je trouve c'est pour en avoir côtoyé pas
mal
andor qui comme vraiment posée car
petite tenue un beau rayonnement mais on
dirait pas force à vouloir faire de
l'auto peu moi c'était comme si ça doit
bien ça merci comme seul ouais non mais
c'est ça c'est là après la presse après
la tournée que tu veux lui donner
tipi sion avant de se recentrer
il y en a qui aiment suis un mec aime
c'est l'attention plus correct le plus
gros hit maison système chose si ces
banques grecques moi c'était le plus
vite possible
on parle plus le seul avocat laïque tout
est allé pourquoi la réponse est non
mais alphonse et d'hommes qui m'avait
donné le défi d'aller faire les autres
ce que l'ue était sûr que je serais pris
six jeunes des partis en voyage ensemble
on avait reçu la nouvelle que ce que
personne n'a fait mieux avec du temps
puis la nouvelle est à la blague mendy
s'est vraiment autour d'une bière cph
tamas sautiller bohy sportif était déjà
ailleurs
quelques uns des facteurs liés comme le
bon package tellement et criminalité a
touché web au niveau des coûts vont
faire fondre et taquet non c'est une
amie qui fait que c'est la société pris
place est devenue respecter gageure par
ici puis en même temps je pense que le
jeu pas pour toi mais tu es je pense que
ça s'est transformé en réel désir de
juste vivre nos intérieurs c'est kiki
que tu vis paul henri viii qui fera
vibrer votre marque et moi je vous dis
je
avec cette espèce de création lille puis
c'est pas moi de poser des questions
mais forme précoce amanites dû réaliser
que cette expérience le allait te
positionner ou te donner à tout le moins
d'ouvrir un champ d'opportunités ex ouin
pis leur statut a décidé ce que tu vas
faire avec est-ce que chez cette fois
comme tout le monde puis de scorer un
show de télé
est ce que je sais faire comme tout le
monde parce que je sais que je vais
sortir de le voir comme ça mais la bonne
est agréable que ce que je fais avec ce
monde dans ma vie un côté stratégique
personne ne le savait pas que ça à voir
si cette ampleur le est là pour la
première année un autre que ça revenait
et y fait que c'est la première année
qui avait ça avec les réseaux sociaux on
n'avait aucune idée l'emploi que ça l'
amour le vin de sortir les avec 130
mille abonnés c'est une autre affaire
comme le demandaient depuis qu'ils se
fixent qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que
puis un potentiel en ce qu il ya de quoi
faire ben oui les mettait en doute ce
juste le podcast n'aurais pas pu si je
n'avais pas eu la visibilité que j'avais
on n'aurait pas les invités qu'on a ça
n'aurait pas été de faire exploser comme
comme ça en rien le fonds affectés à
retirer quelque chose n'hésitez pas ton
but à la base des médias maire de la
ville qui saisit genre je vais une
personnalité publique que l on en
parlait là bas parce qu'on a vu 20 que
les comptes s'est alarmée la météo on
est comme en temps tu parles d'un peuple
je ressens drake puis moi je me rappelle
avoir dit c'est ma vie et des retards
vannes si je me rappelle avoir eu le
déclic de fer cité hôte qu'est ce que je
faisais avant georges tu es content chez
je travaille en alternance ou rejeter je
finissais ma maîtrise toute cette
énergie
j'avais un style de vie qui me
permettait de m'entraîner tous les jours
si j'avais une routine comme juste et
collecte avant se placer comme le déclic
que j'ai eue de dire ok si nous
consommons 10 à 40 mille abonnés au
milieu de l'aventuré
ça va être des bébés gagon sortir ça
sera prêté pendant un certain temps je
pourrai pu aller au centre d'achat le
temps le
ça fait ça change la meilleure du bon là
dedans au sipi tau et au même titre que
parce que je trouve que comme une
similitude avec ce que je vis ça allait
parler l'autre côté moi quand je vois
mon compte instagram est en fait tout ce
que je décide d'entreprendre maintenant
je sais très bien que je vois bénéficier
d'un un boom de visibilité initial ce
que je fais avec après ça ça
m'appartient fait que c'est à moi d'être
intelligent d'en savoir ce que je shoote
dans cette direction diplomatie j'ai
commencé à chanter partout tout le temps
de la dette
fake je savais très bien que quand
j'allais ouvrir mon compte instagram par
exemple que ce qu'ils avaient à voir
plein de monde qui vont me suivre parce
que le mot va se donner à 100 billets de
joueurs de foot on compte encore le suis
maintenant c'est à moi de choisir ce que
je fais avec ce type i au même titre que
quand tu prends ta retraite au foot dès
l'année suivante d'une autre batch de
joie que c'est arrivé un peu en dedans
d'une saison 2 on a honte oublier pilote
c'est un autre idole que les jeunes
regardent allez fêter vos hôtes à tous
les arts il ya une nouvelle bâche de
vedettes en devenir est exact visite il
y en a qui chicaneries stade de
dépression au pays des trucs là dessus
fake faux comme d'un qui battre le fer
pendant qu'il est chaud puis que tu
trouves un créneau
pittis trouver un créneau pour de vrai
que sinon c'est aussi ça c'est super
parce que le monde le jour qu'on a un
détecteur de bauchi assez aiguisées sans
pont de l'ascension on le voit quand le
gars qui font exactement
j'ai vraiment la confection des baises
apostats bien que la pression mais c'est
vrai que ça facilite certaines
opportunités pythie une chose ou si je
pense que motiver ou du moins qui est
vraiment bien tomber dans ton cas sais
qui tu ne prendras pitt c'est une
retraite tout le truc c'est que les
athlètes de haut niveau
ça fait une méchante et d'après le petit
à petit retard
maintenant on tout fait quoi en vie
change entre ta vie tu définis comme ça
du jour au lendemain tu peux plus exact
des justes ph 40 est factice ça arrive
plus et comme ken aventure après seule
la vis réorganise puis ça j'imagine ça
le fait qu'il ya eu au moins une espèce
de d'angoise de ville de moi parce que
problématique quand je disais ma vie
était au tabac si je t'ai revenue daudet
on est ce que ma carrière était finie
fait que cette vie là même si je
l'aimais aval existait comme pure
comédie est réinventée c'est exact toi
tu quand quand il la carrière de footeux
fini je comprends que ce que tu dis
c'est quand il y en a d'autres des
athlètes qui vont arriver après toi qui
vont devenir des idoles
par contre des sportifs qui sont qui ont
la capacité à exprimer ton à petit et
aptitudes de communication qui sont hors
du commun dans les mains sinon ce sont
les gens dont les gens d'aller dans les
sportifs ces présidents les sportifs et
wii puis surtout très réussie est
démarqué par ce pays c'est sûr je pas
d'accord qu'il y en a qui vont arriver à
prêter a fait de super g j'ai eu
beaucoup d'accidents saas ou encore une
fois je suis concerné parler mais je
vous le répétez pas si nouveau ici mais
ma mère était comédienne très très axé
sur la langue française effective
pourrait elle bien écrire bien
s'exprimer c'est super important
c'est un âne été fatigante paient encore
d'ailleurs à ce jour une faute sur
l'impôt ce même appel passé à lagos a
pas de raison mais j'ai les six mangent
les règles j'ai eu des bons modèles au
site idée matthieu proulx d'hébron et
pelle dé pierre vercheval que vous voyez
aller au foot qui s'exprimait super amis
francophones à montréal qui fait plus
entrevue que les autres le bras face si
j'aime ce hp à ces deux sujets une
opportunité de co animer les tests
pendant ma carrière
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que ça
m'a tout de suite donné la chance de
faire de la télé dans quelque chose qui
est pas du foot mise
pour ça qu'après ma carrière j'avais
tellement mal quand je regardais dégaine
de foot c'est tellement du mal que je
voulais me réinventer ailleurs pu
montrer que je peux juste si j'entendais
beaucoup à y est bon pour un ancien
joueur de foot nord le jeu veut être
juste bon fait que je me suis comme
dissocier du football pendant longtemps
tu es un petit peu plus variété show
business et c'est un email coupe des
missions qui ont rien à voir le foot
puis le sais ce que je peux commencer à
revenir parce que le maintenant je le
sais - je pense que les gens le savent
aussi mais surtout moi avec moi que si
je capable de faire les deux c'est fake
rendu le 7 une question de polyvalence
qui je crois dans la vie est quelque
chose de très très sympa est ce que tous
avaient à l'époque de jeu que salah est
son après-carrière 0 ah ouais vous avez
moi tout ce que je rêvais 7 jouent au
foot je voyais pas plus loin
mais ce dont je vais vous confier de
quoi cette année à la fin de l'année
2018 j'étais à bout de souffle
j'ai animé trois shows télé j'avais un
docu j'ai lancé ma bio je fais de la
radio tout l'été avec pat groulx que
j'étais comme vraiment brûlé mais ça se
finit dans ma tête piquée à la fin
d'année c'est là que j'ai eu le premier
temps de prendre un peu un peu de recul
pacinotti d'art grande finale d'études
et où le taps gare et dames et topol la
perspective de touristes puis je me suis
retrouvé à 2,1 à être un peu un sécurisé
par la télé parce que la télé ça pogne
puis quand même c'est à part des gros
shows comme comme aux dés mais sinon il
ya toujours un roulement de nouveau show
à tous les ancêtres en sorte que tu
travaille très fort sur une prod avant à
nantes peu après ça revient pour faire
je peux pas me fier là dessus pour la
suite 10 pour l'heure je vais avoir de
la stabilité fait clair j'ai comme fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'introspection aux
moustiques acheté en secondaire 3 j'ai
décidé que j'allais jouer au foot pro
fait que j'avais un objectif à long
terme qui était clapistes un objectif
qui peut pas changer une ligue de foot
pro il va en avoir encore dans 20
d'entre eux ont fait que cet objectif
loyers fixes plus juste à déterminer les
étapes qu aux membranes et après ceux de
l'appliquer à tous les objectifs dictés
ton chemin ouafqa alors que maintenant
tu maintenant lesquelles etienne c'est
quoi ton objectif dans 20 ans
j'ai aucune est décodé puis ça m'a
beaucoup beaucoup et sécurisé je
comprends pas comment on voit qu est ce
qui va arriver j'ai piloté je me dis
mais c'est pas bon parce que là ça veut
dire que je vis au jour le jour sans
jamais avoir un espèce de lignes
directrices fait je me suis pris trois
jours dans un chalet un ami qui m'a
passé son chalet je suis parti tout seul
avec un bloc notes puis des trucs j'ai
décidé de faire je me dis si on changer
le format de passer des objectifs au
lieu que ce soit d'une erreur de même si
je revenais en arrière fake je me suis
posé les questions juste aller loin le
temps de me trouvait trop dit mais je me
suis posé des questions sur mes valeurs
c'est demain que ce côté valeurs la
famille l'amitié 6 mais c'est quoi tes
valeurs pour de vrai et puis ce thème
pour jeunes en parlent ouvertement c'est
juste comme qu'est ce qui dicte mes
décisions que je prends fait installer
sur l'internet
c'est vrai encore liste des valeurs les
valeurs comme 300 est qu un logis j'ai
jeté les par élimination se tait comme
c'est cool ça vaut qu'on s'y plus patin
patin patin puis gergaud j'ai fini par
faire un regroupement de cinq thèmes qui
font partie de mes valeurs je me suis
dit ça ça veut dire que pour la suite
des choses même si j'ai pu m'en veux les
décisions que je prends que je plains
que ça concorde un joint temps alliée
avec ce c'est ce que j'essaie
d'appliquer puis des fois ce pro facile
parce que l'autre pose la question qui
souffre d'un contre payant merci ça me
ressemble pas tout je fais 2040 et
valeurs ça c'est la question moi la
vérité c'est que oui oui c'est vrai mais
puis je m'appuie j'ai pas honte de dire
qu'on a faut avoir honte de parler
d'argent comme oui moi je les mets dans
mes valeurs faire de l'argent parce que
c'est quoi sa machette et spa pour
m'acheter un char aussi ce tant mieux si
jusqu'à sa machette une liberté
j'ai le goût de partir en vacances avec
la famille la semaine prochaine puis que
j'ai pas une scène je peux pas un messie
jégou puis j'ai l'argent j'ai plus fait
fait que j'ai besoin en fait c'est comme
de vivre aisément s'attendre à tout
oui cet exercice d'introspection tu me
donne vraiment envie de faire ça parce
que mais c'est faux que 26 ans et je
pense que les deux ont vite parce que
les deux all it en modèle gestion du
jour le jour puis projet puis jordan a
piqué ce qui se passe là mais la
question des visions à long terme dans
le maquereau sous la dent c'est ça de
dire dans vingt tapis effectivement
merde je me reconnais beaucoup dans ce
que tu dis parce que pendant sporting
longtemps c'était comme je veux ben
sassi modifier une puce est au début
juin à lausanne un pic quand j'ai
réalisé que ça arriverait pas pour moi
j'ai transféré sans je veux gagner le
championnat canadien universitaire puis
tout ce que je faisais à chaque jour et
d'accès sur farceur cci comme 5 en avant
la menace tu me demandes dans cinq ans
avant qu est ce que je veux faire mais
si tu avais la réponse il y aurait un
problème dans le sens où la vérité le
conseil a mal on sait pas à quoi ça va
ressembler notre monde dans cinq dix
quinze ans plus que jamais en 1960 on
savait de quoi aller à quoi allait
ressembler 1970 à quelques détails près
là on est dans une période challans donc
je vois je vois tu lire une courte le
que j'ai pris en note parce que je lis
je lis pas mal de qui excuse moi je pose
chaque surfeur ça vient du livre les
clés du fitr du futur par jean staune
certains français nous sommes
aujourd'hui au moment crucial où l'on
assiste à la fin d'une civilisation et
où la prochaine n'est pas encore en vue
et si ça peut sonner très très
dramatique mots voici comme quelque
chose d'excitant
on sait ce qui se fera plus bon c'est
pas trop ce qu'ils voient ce qu'ils nous
ont donné l avantage de vivre dans cette
période peut-être dans 50 77 un autre
ils vont avoir une idée claire du
cerveau nous autres on est dans cette
période là où tu peux guère s'est
intelligemment tu peux dire pour le make
up mais ça risque d probablement fait qu
on est là d'un fixe pour ça que je te
dise tu me dis moi dans 20 ans je sais
ce que je veux faire mais tant mieux
mais je vais avoir un titre sans jouer
comme il ya des grandes chances que
que tu crois qu'ils vont être maintenant
ne sera plus je pense que ça devient
dans 20 ans qui je veux être oui parce
que ce salon exact de transit et valoir
d'être dans 20 ans quelle version de moi
même
qu'est ce que je vais faire apprécier
apprécié quand il est une décision qui
intervient le tu peux prendre tu peux tu
peux choisir quatre choix que tu as fait
tu peux prendre une décision selon ce
que tu veux dans sa vie à servir à nous
mêmes
un film plus que jamais dans cette
période dans laquelle on est on a besoin
d'un espèce de capacité d'adaptation
site est ancré dans tes idées puis dans
tes patins même année calais car le
tableau change tout vouloir constamment
faire ça fonctionnerait plus survie de
la frustration
je commençais à chiots les robustes et
tête à tête à tête je marche put à cause
de sa cause de la langue occitane à
mettre la personne justement que se
retrouvent vingt ans trottoirs mauvaise
place les un exemple ok donc encore une
faute côté professionnel je ne fais à
qui je travaillais à radio qui me dit
que ma mère est découragés parce que est
au comptoir à la barque depuis quand les
gens arrivent pour faire une transaction
comme pour trop compliqué il faut que
les dirigent ou au guichet automatique a
dit à capote parce que comme en train de
mener à sa propre perte
c'est comme à la voix légère elle envoie
les gens au guichet
les guichets pu voir toutes les
transactions qui elle faisait ce
document va perdre sa job fait que ces
deux choix cette personne ne peut
combattre pc de pau et dirigé le haut 6e
mais c'est inévitable que ce changement
le sans vie fecteau mieux d'embarquer
l'adapt renouveler ces pays là où ça
vient dans un patin été ressenti dans le
sens où nous on le sait notre génération
que même le jour où on sera rendu à 50
55 60 à sion n'a besoin de recommencer
ailleurs à l'eau je pense qu'on a une
génération de montres qui aux vues qu'on
sait qu'on est capables qu'on a un
espèce de niveau de polyvalence assez
élevé mais nos parents les autres leur
partir à neuf à 55 avions fait la même
job toute leur vie c'est extrêmement
un plus pour notre population qui est
vieillissante aussi deux si on est les
avancements médicaux sont mieux on prend
il va avoir on va arriver à un point où
on va être plus vu pas falloir qu'on
s'ajuste dans quelque chose qu'on n'est
pas habitué ça va être stressant mais je
pense qu'on voit est équipé pour le fret
ce changement le ce changement là est
inévitable de raison puis je peux
comprendre d'où est ce que quand oeuvre
dans un média comme la télévision tu te
retrouves avec une réelle incertitude en
ce moment ça pour de bon ses pépites et
encore une fois on y parle un petit peu
dans le temps quand tu commences hélas
les médias la consécration le but ultime
c'est d'abord ton propre shoot très
astucieux bus tu si haute que ce qui va
vraiment payé t bills si je vous donne
un exemple je fais pas mal d'affaires si
je donne des conférences je suis de la
radio y aller le volet réseaux sociaux
qui prennent plus en plus place puis à
la télé fait qu'à la fin de l'année dans
mon espèce de trois jours de retraite
fermée le lac à l'épaule j'ai fait le
calcul
comme mes quatre sphères versus l'argent
que ça m'a amené mais surtout versus
l'énergie que j'ai déployé pour voir ce
à travers ce malgré trois shows télé ou
un docu c'est possible que j'ai fait le
plus de mon argent avec andy comme moi
manet faut que je prenne une décision
par rapport aux ratios énergie et
puisque ça me rapporte ces projets
d'être leur ouvrant tout le temps mais
si on sait quelque chose qui te demande
très peu de travail exemple me tend une
association instagram x qui fit avec les
affaires je te donne un exemple de
sports experts qui tapait parce qu'une
nouvelle ligne de maillots de bain pas
c'est fake des speed rouge en fait j'ai
fait exactement sur pour des souliers de
course bambins tu vois ce s'affiche déjà
avec qui tu es mais avec ce que tu fais
ça te demandent quoi enflammer ou par
une photo puis le poster comme le lait
l'espèce de deux ratios énergie versus
cash que ça te ramène chez certains que
ce soit intéressant c'est exactement ça
peut pas être toujours ce parce que je
crois que ton corps c'est l'espèce de
le terme influenceurs qui lui sert comme
une connotation négative maintenant mais
je trouve pas que ton corps peut être
d'être influencé ses fautes elle quelque
chose de plus pertinent à offrir à moi
la vie jeu de la pub fait mon avis je
n'en porte pas
mamani je trouve ça s'essouffle c'est
parce que des gens capables d'être porte
parole avec du ridge vous venez pour
n'avoir d'autre que toi tu le site hôte
et le portrait comme une copine il faut
dire que mais à dix ans s'est associé à
57 compagnies commencent le plus
important dans la série jo faut quand
même qu'ils taillent quelque chose
d'intéressant offrir pour quelqu'un sait
que maintenant c'est maintenant c'est
plus du monde le monde si je pense à
sarah jeanne labrosse mettons là qui
vient de faire ligne de valérie avec
franck hanoh khl s'est elle ainsi rendu
à switch le port en créant son
personnage parce que quand on est dans
une comédiens en étant ce qu'elle est
puis ça c'est comme un résultat de son
autre de ce qu'a fait réel c'est souvent
ceux ci s'appuient moi je pense que je
pense qu'ils vont en avoir de plus en
plus comme c'est toi le site je voudrais
pas te poses start et instagram en étant
influenceurs et en faisant des comptes
rendus beaucoup mutique je faisais autre
chose pilote la chance de faire des
contrats qui la chance qu'un stade g
donne aussi toutes les plateformes
multimédias aussi ses castes aussi c'est
comme c'est comme si j'ai ma propre
chaîne de télé puis je décide ce que je
mets dessus je suis ce que je mène au
dessus du site de combien de temps je le
fais je décide de cacher le fait c'est
fait qu'il ya plus de compagnies de
produits nous réduisons contenu puis le
diffuseur est fermée changement sûr
parce que ça marche pas plu aux
patriotes parce que le c'est un 30
minutes mais dont 122 minutes de télé
vient de publier des maîtres de propre
les enfants ce qui signifie que tu peux
te montrer les facettes de toi que tu as
le goût de montrer qu'ils me le faire de
façon stratégique qui peut le faire de
façon organique petit défaut les deux
fêtes ensemble avec c'est un peu ce que
j'ai fait mon sens où je savais que le
monde me connaissait comme joueur de
foot mais le 6 juin de dissocier du feu
encore faut-il que le monde me
connaissent vraiment fait leur faut que
je trouve le moyen dans ce que je publie
de montrer un coup
ma personnalité ou tous les côtés de ma
personnalité à lui mais depuis que
puisqu'elle à partir de là je vois ce
qu'ils peignent seulement même si je
vais en mettre un
seulement imposé sa pointe c'est puis
surprenamment j'ai commencé mon
instagram comme joueur de foot pilule
les publications compagne le moins c'est
le foot fait alors que chic sur twitter
d'affaires de football qui s'est fait
que le tuner vegas avoir convoqué telle
plateforme
je parle de tout de même en forme mais
tu parler de liberté tantôt justement
puis je pense que si une valeur à la
gérer la génération qu'on peut attribuer
ses désirs lieu de liberté
m est-ce qu'on fait effectuer c'est
justement je pense qu'il l'avenir ça
vaut vraiment dans la plaine telle
liberté plein contrôle sur ce qu'on fait
on peut se plaindre parce qu'il ya comme
un couteau à deux tranchants tendance à
sous même au niveau du recrutement au
foot c'est dans t'es tu te faisais
recruté par une cégep universités elles
émettent pis c'était quasiment le but de
courtisaient mais tu savais très bien
qu'ils arrivent et le caecum qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour aider l'équipe
paie recensée comme l inverse quelle
équipe peut faire pour m'avantager - b
ça m'énerve quand même tu as j'admire
sur un petit peu aussi le côté où c'est
comme un peu plus malsain je ne mets pas
les bons de charles quint restos les
propriétaires de restaurants rapides à
gages et des gens la star lady c'est
l'enfant parce que le kid et au
secondaire au tir comme début cégep
première hadj habib belhedi mais moi je
serai pas les vendredis et les samedis
de mafate semaines s'est faite mais qui
se dit puis le il ya aussi bon il ya la
problématique de coton c'est un poème
ont démissionné mais ils font juste plus
présente et bien fait plus exact ces
feuilletons black fini fait que nico
voici ses gosses
génération comme enfin travailler ta
première cabine taureau n'est pas plus
toxique ou la wii c'est comme si avant
on voyait comme québec
ouais la star il ya plus de frontières
pic voir gros c'est correct aussi dès
que je trouve qu'on écoute moins quatre
concerts des espèces de paramètres qui
nous est dit des limitations qu'on
invite dans le prêtre on y en a comme
putis fait que mon appui de plus en plus
de beaux exemples dans tout les soirs au
québec on est choqué c'est que ce soit
au niveau des sparks au niveau des
compagnies comme dans plein de domaines
score bbc parlait de temps vers ses
investissements tant tout seppi je pense
investissements de type monétaire mais
où peut être aussi été personnellement
j'avais j'avais un prof à l'université
au cégep art musique en fait c'est quand
accepter un contrôle cotec c'est une
guide trouille trop facteurs intro
question c'est est-ce que c'est payant
est ce que tu vas apprendre de quoi est
fautif on me dit que c'est d'avoir deux
sur route exacte au moins deux ans
c'est drôle c'est exactement ce que je
me suis installé bien jasant avec un ami
dans le milieu je n'aimerais pas parce
que tu commences à sa convenance elle
est une espèce de sommités dans le monde
de la télé dit lui même ça ne guérit pas
[Rires]
mais tier 1 est ce que ça me tente de
stupéfiants ouais super âge il découle
un la proportion énergie terre et une
récente trop ce que ça me tente
si tu payes en savoie dessus ça vote
immédiat avancé troisième affaire puis
la quatrième que je rajoute est ce que
est ce que je vais amener quelque chose
de plus à ce projet là je te donne un
exemple on demande
on me demande de même atteint le
d'animer un show d'agriculture ok moi
c'est payant qui coûte ça va tu m'aider
à avancer
oi qui jeta telesis un concert ça me
permet de continuer de vous
ce tulle fans bah ouais que je vais
découvrir des affaires jamais une petite
quoi ce projet là vraiment non c'est la
question la plus dure à répondre puis la
plus dure à dire je pense pas que c'est
une bonne personne apprendre l'humilité
oui vous avez les multiples fautes est
cité comme le repos financièrement il
faut qu'ils sentent un peu stable c'est
pourquoi je trouve que c'est une
question intéressante à se poser à
savoir comme dans la perception des
jeunes jamais eu une plus value à ce
projet là où je peux juste assez puis
quelqu'un d'autre peut le voir tph peut
le faire qu'ils servent servent est au
moins aussi bon je tousse maintes fois
des projets dans lesquels je sais que je
vais score et puis je vais me mettre en
valeur
si tu votes un dispensaire examens oui
en fait que c'est tout dire ça mais
c'est vrai que c'est en fait t'es pas
obligé avant le check list au complet 6
mai d'acteurs note de 3 sur 4 la bonne
direction